never now you got an f6 that's the point
okay please put the King on h8 and are
you there just in time
still lady oh my God he's still mated
you can't play the brook over oh that
was a sick draw doing shakes his head is
that is that a theoretically hold a
blank it like it was winning go back
okay
people hyped up for the matchup on the
table today with a nice Giri taken on
what in many ways was one of the biggest
storylines last year Yann Christophe do
des epic epic tour to the semi-finals
where he upsets Sasha Grichuk we are
here from Studio C I am international
master Danny wrench thank you for being
here get at us on Twitter
use the hashtag speech s you can also
tweet at me directly and of course you
can also tweet directly at my partner
who are gonna be bringing on right now
the one the only Grandmaster Robert has
how excited are you especially after
seeing that clip that reminded us of JK
DS epic performance last year yeah made
me want to text my mom get a hug from
her but that was such a great moment in
the SEC and I'm so pumped Danny for this
match I know I'm not supposed to have
favorites but this is my favorite
matchup around one it really is and
honestly we were we were hanging out
with the two of them beforehand and I
even said hey guys no matter what
happens I love you both and of course
Aneesh responded very quickly no you
have to choose so but I really do feel
like I love both these guys a nice Giri
obviously a very well known commodity
here at chess calm has done commentary
and it's just known as one of the one of
the biggest and best personalities to
follow on Twitter on social media
Twitter and Instagram and JK D is just a
rising star he's a guy that it really
burst onto the scene last year not just
in our own speech s championship Robert
but overall is continuing to move up the
ranks and a lot of people look at him as
maybe a future a future challenger to
the world title over the over the next
decade so we're very excited we're happy
to have all of you with us we already
have 2000 of you we hope you're as
pumped as we are and let's remind
everybody of the bracket overall and of
course we've talked about this matchup
here Robert but we've had a few in the
books now you had the pleasure of
calling one of them without me Yonder
pom neon she's victory over Elena
Danielle Ian but MVL got by Grandmaster
Wei Yi and ding li Ren got by Sam
Shanklin I'm gonna ask you to predict
who's gonna get by today because neither
one of us wants to choose between Anish
and young Kristoff but any thoughts on
the bracket so far and the matches that
we've had in the books well I thought
that ding li Ren was very impressive
considering I didn't know that he really
played online at all so I was surprised
you know how dominant he wasn't that
match of course he started off really
hot then Tim ran out a bit and then got
hot again so I think that Dingley ran
he's his classical chest is amazing
right now his online chest seems pretty
good and that would be a great matchup
in round two of Dingley Wren versus John
DePalma sure yeah can't wait for that
can't wait of course for the match we're
gonna see today of course the winner of
today's match likely has the pleasure of
facing hit car Nakamura in round two of
course Vladimir both will have something
to say about that before it's all said
and done and our viewers already having
something to say in the chat with those
bits we really appreciate it
let's remind everybody the format as we
close in here on the start time each 20
19 SEC match features three portions you
know it well it's 90 minutes of five
minutes 60 minutes of 3-1 and then
everyone's favourite 30 minutes of
bullet actually I think 3-1 is
everyone's favourite okay so I take that
back it's my favourite the bracket is a
single-elimination knockout that's
that's what we have in store every year
with the speeches championship been
doing this for a few years now and and
we like we like this one the winner of
each match of course advances to the
next round in the bracket that's the
prize they're playing for to move on but
what else are they playing for cash
money homie that's how I say it to my
kids and they say dad you're so cool
when you say it like that cash money
homie well you know I sound so cool when
I say things that are cool as a dad but
anyway we've got a lot of money on the
line as you know the first round is
already already pretty good but then it
only gets better as the stakes get
higher we have our two players Yan
Christophe Duda of Poland a nice giri
from the Netherlands I'm excited I'm
pumped I know you're ready Robert any
final words before the games liftoff
here I'm super stoked I I don't know
what to say because I can't you say we
don't want to predict who's gonna win
this matchup I have no idea who is going
to win this matchup I think it's a dead
even matchup they have different
strengths different weaknesses I just
want to get see the action get underway
yeah well the games are gonna be
beginning here in just seconds we expect
it to liftoff we'll talk of course about
what our smarter chess predictions
predicted and talked a little bit of
course about these players remind
everybody who they are and what we
expect as it gets going but without
further ado here we go young Christopher
Duda guess white in the first game and
we have liftoff an Italian and a
stallion I don't know I'm just talk
about you we have an Italian on the
board we have a stallion next to me this
is gonna be a good day well I thought
you were about to just give Fabiano the
nickname Italian stallion I was gonna be
like well he's not playing here I don't
know what's go
I was about to go nuts there because the
the one and only chess made herself just
through the subs this way I don't know
if that's just the love of the morning
we're getting from Bay thank you so much
or if it's that we know that these two
guys are also two of her favorite
players especially a niche giri so thank
you so much chess pay and thank you to
everyone who's with us the hype is real
and we just started yeah thank you so
much chess Bay always so supportive the
chess world and well two of everybody's
favorite players I hope between Yann
Christophe Duda and a nice period
because some people who may not be
familiar with them a nice carry wannabe
highest rated players in the world
Yann Christophe Duda the number two
currently for Poland Diaz been number
one but just 21 years of age
extremely young extremely talented and
was the absolute highlight of last
year's speed chess championship well
he's got his work cut out for him we
know that a niche has never made it as
far as the semi finals in the speeches
championship all three years he's
competed but we also know that he takes
this event very seriously he practically
had himself on mute before the match you
could see that game face right it was
real and we know that a niche doesn't
want to fall victim to JKD like like
alexandra grishnack and others did last
year so let's dive in and analyze a
little bit of what's going on here as
these guys are playing pretty much
theory here right popular theory as we
know it these days the Italian is is in
style these variations offer both sides
a lot of flexibility Robert I'm just
kind of rolling through we have this H
six line which sometimes is played with
really aggressive intentions like g5 on
the Kings side we see that being an in
vogue idea a lot but usually it only
happens everyone once White has played
h3 as that move is now a target to kind
of pry things open so after moves like a
six gear
trying to be flexible you'll note that
JKD never gives in that option so Aneesh
decides I'm gonna submit all Castle play
the more traditional lines with Bishop
e6 but after this trade is happening
Robert and white is evolving on the
Queen side black doing his thing on the
Kings side this looks very much what
does it look like it looks like Caruana
grish ik from the Paris rapid and blitz
right it looks like games we see a lot
these days where blacks gonna do his
thing over here on the Kings side try to
make sure these double pawns are helpful
in the open F file
and white just wants to win over time
with the space advantage on the Queen
side while while sort of squelching
blacks attack over here on the Kings
side right did I did I set the tone
properly here anything to add that was a
perfect summary and it all comes down to
who's initiative comes first because
well this move g3 says you're not
getting the Knight to f4 where you may
have sacrificial possibilities but of
course Geary goes back to f6 we're now
Knight g4 is a threat hitting this
Knight and f3 so King to g2 is probably
going to be played here and that's what
as you point out it's what all is gonna
come down to in black be first in the
kingside or is white eventually gonna
play for a b5 push or if you know I can
make it work play d4 in the center
likely b5 is the way to go at the right
moment but it's very far off I tend to
like black in these positions because
the aggression on the Kings side feels
more potent than the whatever hope you
may have of breaking through on the
Queen side yeah and it's especially from
a practical point of view we talk about
that a lot right and in these formats
because with less time on the clock
things like attacking someone's King are
often even more dangerous than they
would be in long time control affair so
I agree with you I guess I look at these
positions also get get a little bit
excited about blacks potential attacking
chances but there's a reason why we see
the best players going to these
positions now with both colors you see
guys like 5 in a car want to play
consistently with both sides Vishy Anand
playing it consistently with both sides
at the high level because I think it
offers flexibility and it offers
everything you said right if black has
counter play which you don't always get
as the second player and a lot of other
openings and it offers white you know
the flexibility a very very solid center
and many options as you said b5 open up
the Queen side maybe you go d4 at some
point also if you can just so
sit tight and stop this counter play
although look at that move backing up
the rook from defending f3 gets me a
little worried
I wonder what his coordination ideas
here but if you can stop attacking ideas
on the Kings side then white may be
better long-term positionally okay here
we go b5 and I'm also worried just about
young crystals time because okay it's
not that great of time trouble just yet
but as you'd be the first to point out
it reminds you of a Robert hats with the
white pieces against someone with the
black pieces and why is he down so much
time I'm just first to point out your
mistakes that's your mother I'm number
two no you're number one the serious
note he is getting himself into huge
time trouble right now a knight of
forecheck being a threat is why I went
Queen to e3 yep if he if he can combine
a thread on the clock with threats on
the board seem to spell really big
trouble for Duda in this first game yeah
well said
and now after Queen e3 Gary's gonna take
a moment I think this is his opportunity
to like you said like come up with
something tricky that is gonna make it
hard for JKD to solve in time pressure
again if we use that acraman acronym is
just because it sounds awesome young
Christophe Duda JKD is kind of his
nickname but he's earned throughout it's
an acronym nickname but we'll talk a
little bit more about nicknames here in
a little bit okay look at white trying
to relocate flip the script there's
outside ideas of taking h6 no not
anymore
Devin look at look at the full board
execution though b7 is a target there's
opportunities maybe to get to get going
on the the King side I feel like on the
board this one has sort of turned around
right now I'm liking you on Christoph's
approach I am as well because he's very
active there on the Queen side and this
pawn on b7 will forever be a potential
target but that's why gear went d5 a
timely break in the center I need some
sort of counter play otherwise I'm just
gonna rolled over it now I don't think
the counter play is sufficient
especially now the c-4 square it's freed
up for the white knight again and look
at the nice you played d4 very quickly
and they need to think about how to
recapture I think it's a very bad sign
yeah ever you move quickly and then I'm
like wait a second yeah actually
really no I'm gonna do because if you
play 95 to stop this nightmare to c4
then what head at 4 which is why you
need to play Queen g5 say well if you go
out for now I'm gonna take with my rook
and then you're just wandering pause
yeah I'll show the fork at the end of
that line because everybody loves Forks
the the move Queen g5 met by nice c4
though as you said because that was the
whole reason to want to play 95 to stop
this move and look at young krysta
playing super quickly anticipating
Gary's moves here something tells me
that this has this has turned around
young Chris stuff feeling very confident
they're likely wearing some Beats
headphones I don't know he looks like
he's about to throw a mix tape down with
Dre right after this match that's all
I'm saying so he's also playing a great
game range - here comes b7 as that as
the biggest weakness on the board and
that again is part of the storyline of
these Italians those looking for those
educational nuggets they get out of
these events when the top players play
even if it is what's this is this is I
mean Robert Lake this is not a bad game
to base how you want to play these
positions as white on five minute or not
right I mean this has been a pretty
model game for white squelching blacks
play on the kingside using the space
advantage slowly on the queenside and I
think that if JKD gets this one this is
that this is a game you remember about
how to play the white side of these
modern Italians it's look beautiful I
was about to say move h5 felt like
Gary's only chance of creating some sort
of counter play on the kingside because
otherwise he doesn't anything going the
Kings side his b7 pawn as you pointed
out is the weak on and that's the key to
these structures right watch base ponds
are the most vulnerable White has this
pawn on d3 that's almost impossible to
get to and the other pawns are also
quite safe which is why I think got
Chris off made a mistake with this ePHI
move as it allowed a niche to get some
counter play here and right now H takes
g3 look what he just did you just took a
pawn on e5 now g4 is hanging next yeah
allowing this h5 seemed like a big
mistake now with the 19 chief or fails
Queen e6 check rook ups on Queenie a
check and you take the rook on f8 and
fork with 96 at the end okay gotta show
it BAM slam jam take on f8 thank you
ma'am I win a rook at the end of the
line this is a huge moment right here
and a trap that Jake had you set up you
see Gary leaning in he's not sure how
deal with this also note that trading
Queens okay
there's there's taking e5 to consider
but even if the Queen's come off this is
how white would just win
straight up using this very very
powerful past b-pawn Wow so gary has to
settle on rook e8 and don't kid yourself
that is a settling move because you
don't want to play a passive move like
that in a short position like this yeah
it's very sad move to have to play and I
think that's a sign of what's gonna come
in next few moves and that's gonna be a
victory for you on Christophe Duda he
earned it really he played a very good
game he pressed on the Queen side as we
anticipated and gave his opponent
nothing to work with on the Kings side
and right now it's looking looking
pretty done he's removing the guard him
get be a square he's just improving his
pieces and as you said even without
Queens on the board that beep on will
run free yeah he's he's pressuring the
the e pawn the b-pawn can't be taken
okay you just got to deal with threats
threats on the F file now can you just
okay he removes from check but you're
threatening to take on e6 with the
knight the time pressure is still a
thing though here right Oh rook F - did
he miss this that was smart moves like
you just simplify it he's getting such
great time trouble just solves it
if he goes Queen f4 is makes say either
you trade Queens with me or I take your
knight on b8 next and if you have to
trade Queens as you point out a long
time ago all endings are good for white
you are both up and pawn and have this
past pawn on b7 but I think that Gary is
gonna throw in the towel soon well I'm
almost not ready to say that just
because of the time if there's any sort
of tricks left but okay after this check
if you've run out here comes Queen f5 I
think yeah cause if I'm maintaining both
the defense of the f1 square and
bringing in the threats okay but look at
Gary he's trying to make something magic
you'd like to play g5 but is he gonna
have to settle because Queen he wants a
threat now you've created quite weak a
draw oh my these blenders to perpetual
you are so good and recognizing when
time troubles and cause blenders only
because it's been the story of my life
bro we learned from your own
experiences here well there's only one
direction to go from there so it's a go
did you just bring Harry Styles into
this show and he didn't even want you to
I love it just like that we've got
everything in the books right Vegas
Vegas bookies lose cuz we mentioned One
Direction story of my life one of their
biggest hits and Harry Styles in a chess
show and we're not even 15 minutes in
but doing them do you think it's gonna
have any impact in the rest of the match
of course by score it's now half half
but do you think for young Christoph
that's going to make him a little
jittery that he was playing so slowly
that he had a winning position and I
threw it away for sure he threw that
away right and and I mean we started
looking at it in the end and you could
see the Giri was settle it was trying to
set up these little you know perpetual
ideas we would have to have time to back
up and figure out the coordination of
exactly how I should stop it but like I
said that's where time pressure you know
youyou called it earlier so you said I
was good at predicting and I'll say that
you foreshadowed it earlier correctly
because I think that the nerves really
showed there for duda he is the younger
player despite his success last year the
fact is he probably took a lot of time
on moves in that game Robert that he
could have played faster and that time
pressure eventually catches up with you
right winning patient or not it
definitely worried me when I saw he had
a minute and a half or whatever and in
each had four minutes it just doesn't
feel right for a blitz game but what
does feel right here is blacks control
of the center you look at this east six
pawn saying your Knights never getting
to d5 this Pony six is a potential
target but you can only really attack it
once right you can put a queen on g4 and
that's all you're getting out of the
position these are these are again okay
so this is a Sicilian there's some
similarities to the last pawn structure
we had everyone with black having the F
file combined with doubled yet very
useful very effective pawns in the
center and some of the theme is a little
more simplified here and that and that
black doesn't have as many pieces to
expect to checkmate attack but also
White doesn't have as many pieces to use
the space advantage that might occur on
the Queen side so interesting we've had
a couple of structures that are kind of
similar for for those watching here and
trying to take away some educational
nuggets of how these guys approach these
positions and it's going to come down
speaking of educational nugget said the
knight versus the bishop right a knight
can go from color to color so the knight
can't operate in the light squares this
Bishop on e7 is sort of stuck sitting
passively right now but it's not that
big of a deal because there are no break
through house ebony sounds terrible and
often feels bad when you're playing with
it but right now all of a sudden you're
like well where does white go what's
White's plan and I think that white
should do similar to what young Krista
did last time expand on the Queen side
well now you're not doing yeah because
not anymore
but I thought they ate four before the
rook went to d1 would have been in the
cards and said he settles for a3 a more
team approach and anisha's going for the
long game here this wants to say okay I
have a three on two on the Queen side
from the age your C files you're on
center if you can try to play for d5
well they need to worry five pawns
you're not getting that into anytime
soon so I do think that the stability of
White's position will allow him to just
threaten little things here and there
perhaps put a work on c1 at the right
moment or rewrite this night from g4 to
e3 and potentially say well you till we
worried about c4 even if I won't play it
yeah here he goes he likes your idea
puts the knight on e3 it's it's straight
you have to like Gary's position here I
think d6 is is the biggest weakness on
the board but the problem is those are
sort of like superficial evaluations
concretely taking advantage of the weak
pawns is a whole nother deal although
look at the knight right gonna continue
to poke and prod that's something you
can do in blitz even without a clear
plan look how gear look how fast gear
he's playing here he's up a minute again
on the clock objectively it's not like
white is doing anything super flashy but
I like the way that he's working it here
you've got this weak pawn you've got
this weak pawn at some point the
practical aspect of defending a slightly
worse position under time pressure
becomes a reality and I think
grandmasters teach us that all the time
Robert you're one of them grandmasters
one of them you're one of those people
who shows that sometimes you can win by
continuing to put pressure you don't
always have to have the most brilliant
plan in the world right yep and it's
exactly what
Anish is doing you know you're
recognizing it perfectly queen g4 comes
them
we just said I the e6 square so you need
to tie your pieces down to it then you
can even consider playing pawn h4 I know
we're told not to move pawns in front of
our King but playing were like h4 you
just gained a bit of space
you kicked this Bishop from g5 where it
is pretty annoying and they got to push
through it me honestly you're thinking
with f4 as well because now that Kings
in f7 if I can get f4 in at the right
moment all of a sudden I'm blasting open
the King side and your king is sitting
there just waiting to be attacked I like
to move h4 it's what I would play LM an
h4 and don't play h5 right away because
then the bishop will come right back but
just the threat and the pressure it's
the practical balance Gary's playing
with right now on both sides of the
board exactly done and you're saying
this bishop is very active here on g5
once I kick it back to say you know
visual f6 or something like that now
your bishop is staring into its own pond
yep so he brings his knight back to e3
which I think I tend to prefer to stare
into my own pawns but I'm a weird chess
player right most people don't know
jokes decided diamond remember my p2
says that giri is channeling his inner
nakamura just kind of playing quickly
here and practical moves putting
pressure on the position we like that
twitchchat thanks again to chess pay for
all the love we've seen some more subs
and for everyone that's with us
don't go anywhere the show has just
begun I think we're in for a thriller
today absolutely I mean this is gonna be
a tight match through and through right
now in each Geary up a minute and 10
seconds on the clock
I think that's relatively normal unlike
last game we're so early stages and it
felt like young christophe was just kind
of i was a wasting time but
unnecessarily using time here it feels
like time well spent because I do think
white is better black doesn't really
have anything going on if you play d5
which is a movie you'd like to play to
get more space for yourself then you're
freeing up the f5 square once I capture
on d5 you capture their east 6 pond and
that piece exponents so valuable because
it protects squares it just stops the
knight from infiltrating so I would
probably not play for d5 at least I'm
surprised that h5 because that frees up
g5 right back and and that blocks Queen
b6 but I wonder what Geary is thinking
about this he must be eyeing some sort
of practical idea of both about the
long-term light squares ooh and maybe
this idea of the night coming to g4 now
what does than I do on g4
is he my wonder if he's got I wonder if
he's got vicious ideas of sacking I mean
I
so one crazy long-term plan here with
Knight g4 Robert is he moves the Queen
and actually plays for g3 and f4 and
okay and I know that seems crazy but if
you if you can't really leave the d6
pawn because let's point out if you move
either one of these rooks then Knight
takes e5 is a real tactic because we
have a pin so I think what he's doing is
preparing g3 and f4 based on the fact
that the rooks are kind of stuck that
makes sense right so you just say I can
break through on the Kings side while
the rooks are tied down I like it I like
the ice-cream shark in the background to
truck I could go for a you know I don't
know a snow cone right now
ice cream Chuck from now when we hear
sirens behind you in the New York City
Lights I'm gonna assume they're ice
cream trucks rather than doing what we
mostly assume as humans that it's always
something bad happening from now on it's
an ice cream truck let's get a new emote
for your channel I like your positivity
if only right alright but here I watch
out for this idea I think g3 kingi to
kind of slow jam it over here prepare f4
and white is gonna continue to to be the
one pushing up here we go I like this
plan I think I think URI is is feeling
it look at the clock management to
Robert up a whole minute yeah he's been
really impressive with his speed and I
don't think he's been too fast or we
criticized Jana Palma she in the
Sinquefield conference moving too fast
at critical moments I think that Andy
she's just been quick because he
understands the positions quite well
look at that little maneuver yeah that
was a game of tickle and I was right
you're not even playing how do you
somehow I always win in the game of
tickle it's really weird but I do it I
don't even know um but look at this he
just he's working it
maybe he comes to b3 at some point
though he has to stop with the
fiddlesticks here and and go for it
he might be from at some moment because
if he figures he's nothing better to do
he mentally repeat too many times and
you're gonna earn your nickname a nice
giri known as the artist formerly known
as Prince he kind of looks like a pop
star by the way he does he does Oh
before he pushed the
before we go he avoids the draw but does
that help I think it helps white but the
reason why is this Queen come to a to
now and spine is very nice look at you
look at you I spy with my little eye a
weak pawn on e6 and I think the only way
to protected because Knight takes e5
will be a threat from the rookie a
rookie 7 I just gonna be 5 and I'll show
that again everyone we have a pinned
pawn right here so we take e5 and you're
losing on the spot give it its so if you
take here you actually self trap your
own exchange because the bishop takes
the square so that's a very resourceful
defensive move there but by Duda you'd
love to take and take here first in erm
is Oh but again the rook hangs before
you can take advantage of that pinned
pawn so Queen c4 look at that move by
Duda and found pretty quickly we're
getting closer and closer to being equal
here on the clock whoa and here goes and
each is getting aggressive but in turn I
think that young Kristoff gonna be
aggressive is look at this f3 pawn if
the Queen moves away from a 6 or some
Queen a to check ideas very much tied to
the fact that there's Fischer 1 g5 is
stopping a rook and going to d2 and all
right the hand play d5 of course is the
e5 pawn is hanging but if you could play
d5 and to start hammering through in the
center all of a sudden it we on
Christoph's position that we like yeah
but it's it's now young Kristoff's turn
to figure that out no you can't just
come back to d7 anymore because the
Knight takes e5 threat is real
well we know there's queenie to check on
this campaign this line you can do it
because if Knight takes e5 D takes e5
rook d7 we have queenie to check at the
end of the line in black wins these guys
they're defending each other stress
robert with little resourceful tricks i
love it it's like just the the tone of
the tone of the match is gonna be both
sides trying to catch the other sort of
sleeping at the wheel yeah you said this
earlier right that little moves they
just kind of pause your opponent to
think about what do they need to protect
what squares might be left unguarded
things like that really be difficult and
look
young Chris I was spending some time and
I moved 10 seconds because he probably
thought could I put my Brooke on a eight
or a seven and then go to a to Ben's
like well I lose my d6 pawn I don't have
a follow up so now he's allowing Queenie
to check though at the cost of hitting
the rook we saw diamond remember my my
p2 and the chess TV chat saying why
should put the King on h3 and it looks
like Gary's gonna do that I think right
now oh no he's gonna offer the Queen
trade also very good because white
maintains the positional edges in every
transition and here we go I think I
think Gary's gonna be gonna be taking
this one home I don't know I got a
feeling that with five seconds defending
what maybe it would maybe a very bad
position anyway rook a1 grab be a file
here just do it
Oh get yeah he does it this is
instinctive chess now I think Geary
takes this one with a very very nicely
played full board game yeah the problem
for black is look at this pawn on d5
easy for what to attack it hurts you
can't the attacked White's position and
look at this Knight e3 see to a3 watch
it go alright actually if you go 93 to
quickly then rook to B to C well attack
to c3 pawn so that's why I know he's
being that's why he's trying to walk the
King in the guard c3 his only weakness
really exactly okay here he goes it Oh
h5 maneuver is on I think they do does
in big trouble though he's committed to
the defense now a very passive defense
right okay yep he does it and now the
big issues this rook is gonna be tied
down forever to the b5 square because
you can't move it without my knight
taking my name if I will protect seed
Wow
but why did Erie settled there why did
he settle on that draw there I thought
that he could trade rose and continue
rising poke and prod that was really
surprising I'm not surprised to see the
scoreboard tied at one game apiece if
anyone's just tuning in we expect this
to be a close match I'm a little
surprised how we got there if you just
missed it
JKD had the advantage in Game one really
let it kind of slip and Geary
resourcefully stole a perpetual check in
a bad position here we see URI kind of
led away the edge but alright we have a
great moment now the game is started
here game three let's remind everybody
of who these players are in case you've
missed that memo as these two guys are
two the biggest stars in chess
our smarter chess predictions tell you
who we favor right now even though JKD
has the the slightly better SCC record
lifetime there are actually a 50/50
favorite so you called it Robert when
you said this is quite literally a coin
flip not even our smarter chess
prediction is willing to go out on the
edge and say who's the favor here
look at their power rankings all-time
Geary has it has a number five ranking
all-time in terms of how we rank their
performance in each individual time
control against their level of
opposition even though Duda has a 2-1
record
Gary's ranking all-time is a little bit
higher so your thought there on some of
the rankings and how we look at these
two guys yeah I think the toss that
makes sense I think that due to proved
himself in the bullet last year against
stroke and cardiac in and he was the
comeback kid
yep and for theory I do think he's the
favorite and the longer time controls
but honestly not for the reasons we've
seen thus far we've seen him get ahead
on the clock which has been helping him
obtain ease maybe not the biggest
advantages in the world but some
advantages but in the first game he was
completely lost so I I don't know I like
the time management by Gary I like to
play in this Italian from Duda I do
think that Gary being the stronger
player should be favored in this
five-minute portion plus here he has a
lot of experience playing blitz events
for the grand chest tour he plays all of
the top players Brenda I don't think he
always does super well in those rapid
and blitz events but the experience
should come in handy but Young
Christophe Duda he's really just making
everybody's life difficult in these
speeches champions anytime you play him
he's he's difficult it plays a lot on
our site to polish fire 3000 you can see
his username but a lot of guys who play
on our site and around the world have
earned themselves nicknames over time
we've kind of four shout at our daily
question a couple times so let's bring
it up now because this is a fun one
today we've got a question designed to
get the fans involved hopefully give us
a fun reason why you have a favorite
nickname and you might win a free
diamond membership use the hash tag
speech yes but we have a list of
nicknames some of them I didn't even
know some of them I I've now learned in
the process but a nice giri has the
nickname known as the artist not because
he's related to Prince despite my best
efforts to advise him on his pop
pop singing career but because he draws
a lot of games so he's known as the
artist I love that actually the fun
night and I throw out some of my
nicknames from people go for it go for
it well we have you know it just
succumbed there's a very great
Australian man as you know very well
that's my name but he was playing a game
and he was saying he was playing so
badly so I called him the blunder from
down on the right that's great I love it
that's a great it is a great nickname we
don't and sorry no I was gonna say if
you're if you're looking for names that
we've suggested already as potentially
the best you can vote at chest coms
official Twitter account but obviously
some obvious ones come to mind the briga
magician McKell towel to me that might
be as good as it gets you've got the
beast of baku beast from baku that's
garry kasparov our 13th world chess
champion so many great nicknames we talk
about iron tigran of course that's world
champion Tigran Petrosian the tiger from
Madras that's Vishy Anand Chucky right
you can you can imagine a Von Chuck and
in a little like scary red-haired doll
like him and the way he plays chess
because he's a bit unpredictable you
know anyway let us know your thoughts
you can also vote via the twitch
extension I believe we have that updated
for the daily question let us know your
favorite nickname and we'll let you know
some of the results as they come in
today so fun stuff yeah I don't know
which I'm gonna go with from this list
but I'm you know you could actually know
I'll say who you're talking about cuz we
has another nickname his name's penny
he's our director of media here at chess
comm works with so many of our authors
to record videos and helps produce a lot
of a lot of things behind the scenes
here as far as digital media goes so
shout out to penny and the blender from
Down Under
he's got a sexy accent you know how I
feel about Australian accents don't get
me going talk about that can't talk
about this chess game that's a let's do
it I like once again do this position
the white side of these Italian games
have gone well for the Polish player and
right now it's a critical moment for
Anish does he take on d4 after which I
think Duda will take back with a C pawn
and say look at your pawn he doesn't
immediately had a pre move look at your
pawn on c7 that's a target and whites
pawn on d4 is actually quite a good pawn
despite being isolated
because look at this night on g6 it has
a very hard time going to attack this
pawn takes at least two moves whereas
the pawns offender button nf3 so I
prefer White's Knights I prefer White's
rook on b2 to this rook on d6 and now
this work on c1 is also very nice being
the c7 ball yeah positionally both sides
have split pawns we've got a couple of
isolated pawns for white and the same
for black but it's it's the specific
coordination and the way these pawns are
coming under fire right White's pieces
feel better
they they're able to access squares a
little more effectively the fact that
black is also clearly playing with the
worse of the rook duo right White's
Brooke already having pressure on the
seventh rank and hitting c6 where that
rook on d6 looks like he woke up from a
long night and wonders how he got there
right he's uh he's like I don't even
like where I am but I kind of have to
stay here now cuz nobody else is gonna
guard this week c6 month
94 is a move that is is trying to fix
the problem of the Knights being clearly
worse but there's got to be some
objective objective ways that this is
bad I'm just looking immediately at
night c4 with tempo and then I put my
knight on e5 where they work together to
hit f7 any reason why this idea of
night-night c4 95 isn't isn't on the
agenda where does that where does that
Queen go by the way that's what I was
trying to figure out first and foremost
like where is this Queen belong and
maybe d5 it doesn't look like the best
square in the world but right that's
it's kind of one of the only squares you
have available right I mean the Queen
the Queen lacks a lot of other options
Wow Judah goes for Queen b3 but if this
had happened in 95 which hits f7 and
here I don't know maybe he maybe he
didn't like something about a massive
exchange and f7 isn't as good as it
looks so that's quite possible and
settles on Queen b3 and well see those
nails route 66 would win a pawn because
the f7 pawn is hanging behind that rook
on e6 very nice actually let's show that
so the Queen moves to some random square
BAM slam Queen takes f7 strawberry jam
on g7 let the rhyming scheme I got the
right time today I brought it I brought
the endgame might be the 17 cups of
coffee I'm now rocking my shoes
here for the crowd no
you know when I get on the ride the mic
my rhymes are tight Oh No
okay I regret the Pandora's box that all
right wrote to f8 to guard f7 but still
White's pieces feeling like they have a
better future than blacks
nighty-night c4 excuse me might be met
by Queen d5 now though so dude was gotta
figure out how he wants to improve on
this position black pieces passive but
you definitely consider pawn d5 here
because you know I don't want to get rid
of your honesty six seven targeting but
at least my knight gets very active
there on the d5 squared
something feels so often well this Queen
on a file I can't really get to it and
maybe pawned if I've actually helps you
start trainings and pieces but I just
want to get to the screen on a fivesome
that I don't see a direct path forward
for what which is frustrating when you
have a min in ten seconds and you're
spending your time shout out to a
subscriber Alec SJC for the best flight
of the conchords reference I've seen in
about I don't know probably three months
I see a lot of them but still awesome
stuff my rhymes are bottomless although
I'm known as the chess eponymous but
yeah there you go we've got a lot of
people I think split here we've got a
huge member based on chess calm in
Poland a nice giri has has huge fans
darn diamond member Ariane to Roland
says he's rooting for Geary in the chess
TV chat but I'm curious use your emotes
if you're a subscriber to the chest
channel let us know spam your face there
we go we got set for nine one with the
giri head let us know use the emotes of
the players and tell us who you're
rooting for alright well i will not be
using any most because now i don't take
sides you told me that that's right i
told you that you stated and if i'm
being objective here i think due to once
again is out playing giri look at this
end game that's about to happen yep the
seat will fall and maybe the a pawn with
it both of them are under attack so why
does it at least scooping up a pawn here
and there's nothing that I can do about
because either you trade Queens in which
case one of those pawns going down
immediately or you play with a queen a
or e2 or something like that and say
okay I'm hoping to get enough activity
to counteract the fact
my pawns are still under it's out but
well we have to highlight here is for
the first time if you're just joining us
in three games young Christophe Duda is
up on the clock as both players go under
the minute mark and the one of the
storylines has definitely been that
Geary came out really guns a-blazing
he's been playing faster than his
opponent but not this game right now
Gary is definitely worse probably losing
objectively in an endgame like this if
with best play and down on the clock
yeah I think if you watch let me ask you
Danny do you think there's more chances
to hold in a blitz game or a classical
game III would say that a blitz game
normally but not when you're the one
down on the clock okay now it's about to
become a coin flip but in a classical
game I think that the person who should
win objectively like if we remove any
practical stuff what is the objective
evaluation usually a Brooklynite engine
with that extra pawn it's very difficult
for black to hold these so if you have
enough time to show proper technique I
would root I would I would say the
person who should win should win but the
fact that you don't have a lot of time I
think that hurts the person trying to
convert more than it does the defender
maybe I maybe I'm crazy but I don't know
I think you're right because for the
defense you just think alright if I give
up my F pawn but I get you're a pawn the
two three on the Kings side doesn't feel
as that you just hang gage well now okay
King f1 comes just in time to hit the
knight but here comes Knight c6 no nice
e6 r okay six you lose the knight don't
do that yeah but Knight b3 in the knight
c5 same idea though you're surrounding
the a pawn yeah I think Duda might have
blown it now look at him down the clock
so I think we got our answer I think
this was harder for him to convert than
it was for Geary to defend very nice
defensive technique the eight pawns
falling yeah wonder if you get Thrones
are kind of h5 check at the right moment
but he doesn't I thought h5 was better
just to try to go for some practical
tricks against the King the reason
everyone is h5 would have forced the
King to come this way because moving
backward would hang f7 and it makes you
feel like this King is I don't know
walking into the danger zone but we have
a time scramble wouldn't be funny of the
one game that we think could end in a
draw now we'll be the one decisive game
will get okay maybe not but the the draw
is about to be had
now again if if you're wondering because
this game is just about to be a game of
tickle so I'm gonna run everybody again
of our daily question and it's no
coincidence I think that we've got a
nice giri here again if you didn't know
a nice Geary's name amongst amongst the
highest level and by the fans has been
the artist because he likes to draw and
that sometimes comes across as throwing
shade sometimes it's a high compliment
the guy is very very difficult to beat
so the nickname for Geary being the
artist I think that's that's pretty good
but get involved read the comments
section engage with our official chest
comm Twitter account we've also given
names like the ginger GM obviously he's
a well known streamer the Mozart of
chess of course Magnus Carlsen
we've also I would give my my my shout
out to my producer in the background but
he doesn't really have a cool nickname
yet you see so we'll talk about that
later but there you go get at us on
Twitter well I'll think of a cool
nickname for Oren well really put him on
the spot there my buddy Harlem Knight
likes to call me mr. producer mr.
producer okay I'm okay with that I mean
that sounds it sounds okay as long as
you didn't give yourself the nickname
that it's okay right that's I think
that's rules and it definitely is rules
you give yourself a nickname I don't
think people should call you right it's
it's like it's like like the guy you
know and like you know high school maybe
early called the bro in the gym who's
like yeah like whatever gives himself a
nuke name you know that that doesn't
count that's that's just narcissism and
we'll talk about it later alright well
what we have here is three peaceful
results not due to a lack of fighting
spirit if you're just joining us you
might be in for the one of the best
matches we're gonna have in the first
round of the speech Chess Championship
this is our fourth match of the year and
we've had some good ones but I get the
feeling this one might be closed
throughout yeah and this game looks like
to me close throughout this one as well
we talked with three draws but the first
three games were very fighting chances
for both players in various games
I think Duda has had more chances I
think he's spoiled more good positions
Anish has been struggling a bit
and the just got the precision of Duda
he's really impressed me this far but in
this game look at the niche got with
white the answer is a nothing sorry Nick
Tom had a great comment in the image
which yet that I should be called the
orphan because everyone wants to adopt
me I shout out to a show coming your way
in September as soon as MBL's done with
the World Cup the real fun begins and
that was we launched our adopted Danny
show for those who don't speak twitch
sort of slang an adoption is not meant
to be an offensive term it's meant to
imply that you won 10 games in a row in
a given time control against somebody I
didn't start it that's it you know
anyway there you go I like to comment
there sounds like a show that will only
last 10 games I'm taking the challenge
once people are trying to do it I am
it's gonna be streaming it's gonna be a
multiple affair I think it's gonna be a
huge hit and I I'm gonna go out on a
limb here dude and tell you like MBL's
not gonna adopt me it's not happening so
yeah get ready okay it's it'll be
similar to SCC we'll have three segments
three countdown timers 30 minutes of
five-minute 30 minutes of three-minute
30 minutes of bullet with some breaks in
between maybe longer but anyway he's not
I'm not I'm not going down don't you
worry I am worried and I'm also starting
to get worried for a young Christoph's
position in this game because I said it
was dead even a little while ago right
now looking good for white you have the
night against the bishop very
importantly this night on d3 cannot be
kicked out yep where protects the pawn
on b2 and so white can choose how to
proceed on the kingside there are many
different options here of which pawn you
want to push you can push your F pawn to
f4 first if you feel like I think it's
good then follow up with King out three
then play h4 you can kind of choose your
own adventure on that side of the board
and something not to overlook is if
black says okay I'm gonna king e8 in d7
at some moment that work yb3 a death
that seems like the anti move you want
to play because the pawn was perfect
guarded by the knight and look at Duda
not missing a beat saying why did you do
that
I'm gonna go target your pawn now that
move made absolutely no sense yeah I
don't know what gear you know what he
was thinking he was worried about black
playing b3
and then ideas of Bishop III that was
the idea something that isn't but
there's an item d3 that's stopping all
that right you're right cuz b3 comes and
you go Bishop III and then you just
laugh at the bishop and say what are you
gonna do big guy sit on me right you've
got nothing here I'm surprised by
Geary's b3 move as well especially
because if the if the Queen side wasn't
an issue everyone Robert was
highlighting that white held all the
cards over here lots of ways to push
forward take advantage of these weak
pawns for black and kind of slowly play
tickle amazing common in the Twitter
chats from me Howell 2x he was worried
about winning
he needs a draw he wants to win the best
nickname so maybe Gary is here today to
earn your vote for the best nickname of
all time again known as the artist kind
of looks like he could be related to
Prince but okay I'm gonna i'm voting for
Gary's nickname as the artist I feel
like that's about as good as it gets
it's got five votes I'm looking at the
chat the riga from magician is winning
currently if you hold your mouse over
the twitch player no surprise it's one
of my favorite nicknames beast from baku
has five votes mozart of chess has five
votes so let us know your favorite
nickname of all time i already voted let
me guess you voted for you didn't vote
for the artist nope you either voted for
the riga magician or the beast from baku
yeah unless you think that or you order
for Chucky no I wanted for the Riga
magician okay I don't make you hesitate
for a second you're like get out of my
head Danny fine I know this is this has
been a little bit of a disappointment
let's back up and analyze again Robert
and I questioning Geary's move be three
I think this was definitely a mistake
again
things like f4 allow b3 king of three
just to show there's no reason you even
have to take care and allow exchanges
the white knight is holding everyone's
dreams together you can play h4 h5 even
threaten h6 long term where you have
this H pawn as a target playing king e4
and f5 was even possible Robert because
the
Nandi 3 also held be for like literally
black had no ways to stop white from
plans of just expanding the space right
so really doesn't make a lot of sense
that Giri went for this line
although note that in in time pressure
you probably still prefer the night the
problem is that there's just not really
much on the board to say that why should
win this right why definitely should not
win this whereas I think objectively
that earlier position we talk all the
practical elements but objectively look
great for white and I think that if Giri
loses a close match he'll definitely
want this game back and I'm actually
shrink them try store this game in my
mind to ask him in the post-match
interviews because right now
who'da had the winning position in Game
one he let that one slip this one wasn't
winning not nearly as winning as that
game one game or duda but I mean
honestly is a position that he wins over
the board in a classical game many times
over right well we'll see if he can
continue to to make it hard for Duda
obviously due to has something to worry
about or at least he thinks because he
continues to think loving the engagement
in our chats hopefully social media is
also Rock and use the hash tag speech as
a lot of people have opinions I guess we
missed the beast from Lyon that's MBL I
also call them the Frenchman with three
names but apparently somebody is known
as the Lord of the rooks instead of lord
of the dance I'm not sure who that is is
that your nickname secretly are you the
lord of the Brooks I'm certainly not
Lord as you can throw down in the club
Robert has has some sneaky dance moves
that's why I you know you weren't at the
wedding I was at this past weekend but
somebody must have gotten to you I I
hear I hear a lot of things and you
danced at John Earl's wedding I think I
saw you throwing some bones there oh
yeah bad from black yeah black is struck
and okay let's let's instruct why this
is so hard whenever you have a night
versus Bishop and everything is
centralized to one side of the board the
night will forever be the aggressor ik
it plays tickle on the dark squares to
the light squares back and forth right
back and forth and it's gonna poke and
prod and and create opportunities for
tricks so even if computers can hold and
not get thrown off psychologically at
the different threats very difficult to
deal with combine that with the fact
that regardless of the practical thing
if you just look at the structural
elements of blacks pawns being split
here and white
we having a potential home for this
night this is this was a harder position
to hold from the start we weren't really
happy with how Geary played it earlier
but honestly I guess we should give a
little more credit to the fact that
maybe he felt like simplifying to one
side of the board just forever would
have good night versus bad Bishop Robert
with with potential of working together
with the rook on some devastating
squares over here so somebody may be
Gary wins this one in rook c7 he's
played 3906 rook h7 mate they just take
upon ear g4 which you would normally
like to do now this is the case this is
getting really dangerous for Duda
especially because it's you can't my
pawns
I can go G takes f five and then e five
myself and create a passed pawn Robert
how does he stop this Bishop these six I
guess right then Knight the f6 check and
if king of favor cage seven I think I
think I think rook c7 actually shocked
due to just the way I'm looking at the
board now because suddenly he's like has
just not come developed letting pawns go
backwards yet because he wants to put
that pawn back on f7 and I think I think
Gary's about to erupt d7 is a good move
because you can't move your net away
from age five now right now right away
so play play tempo on the bishop first
yeah the bishop can't take f4 oh you
know what's gonna happen Danny let's say
you play Bishop b8 here and you played G
takes f five okay takes F five and then
e five I'm gonna say exactly yeah but
I'm not gonna let that happen okay well
do two played Bishop c5 he wants to hold
this diagonal instead alright but I have
another idea I wanted to play Knight f6
check and then say forget the center and
play chief I followed by g6 and g7 Bob's
your uncle
you just let me go check mate or j7 r g6
work f7 meat you know what I guess my
brain right now right I got I can
retrieve my bishop there d7 must be made
on the brain must be love on the brain
here okay you can go free hah no I
wanted to G pawn I think that was a good
idea it looked very interesting I don't
know if it probably wasn't gonna quite
work out black had some defensive
resources there but yeah look
look like an opportunity alright he
didn't go for it when you miss you an
opportunity that's called going Mekhi
Phifer when you execute on your
opportunity it's called Eminem so he
went full Mekhi Phifer there and missed
his one opportunity I thought you were
gonna say you make a joke that he went
Michelle Pfeiffer said Mekhi Phifer no
Michelle Pfeiffer had a great career
Mekhi Phifer chose involvement with the
Fast and Furious franchise there you
know guess what we just had Robert our
fourth draw the artist formerly known as
a nice giri first of all what if we
convince him to change his name to a
symbol it's just the one half symbol the
draw symbol oh my god what if we do that
a nice Giri changes his entire name his
entire brand becomes a symbol that'd be
hilarious first of all that would be the
best ever
well someone clip that moment because
I'm gonna suggest it to a niche on
Twitter that he should just change his
name to the symbol the artist formerly
known as a nice giri yeah we should we
should do that well update his avatar
the up the maybe he get a big tattoo you
know not like inglorious basterds style
not on his forehead or anything but
maybe on his arm like a little draw
simple I think just equal equals all
right well we thought Geary was gonna
get that win there I wanted to move g5
we see member K so asking for the score
the score is everywhere buddy it's right
next to their user names on chess com
it's right below their faces and yellow
so there's a lot of places you can see
the score there you're welcome
did you see rogue potato go on EG cuz
there's only half of his name if I was
Sacha Baron Cohen I would also want to
do a new character called on eg that's
so funny
oh we got a good one chess and onion
says Anish his rap name would be 50%
instead of $0.50
50% I love that but that's been used
before so I can't give that person
credit ok sorry chess and onions I'm
taken
credit back Robert Hess the judge ruled
all right we've got another Italian if
you're just joining us we're having a
lot of fun in case you can't tell but
jokes aside this is a very very close
match we've had four draws but not due
to lack of fighting chess both sides
have held on when it matters or spoiled
and it spoiled an advantage squandered
away the victory depending on the way
you choose to look at that storyline I I
think Anita has gotten his best Italian
is black so far in this game Robert I'm
actually actually not happy with Paula
with the Polish fighters position here
as compared to the other Italians yes
definitely feels more aggressive for
black if you have space for your pieces
and do not allow white to play c5 I
think that's should get pretty clear so
black should probably play c5 himself or
which I don't actually really like but
it's fine I would prefer to c5 but the
point here is that black didn't wants to
give white all the space in the position
and look at the D file or is it I
already have a queen on d7 well now I
want to point in d4 and in this position
the e4 pawn already under attack if to
keep an eye on it that's why Queen c2 is
played and I guess I'm not entirely sure
how black doesn't continue look f d8 or
you know I like rook F T because my pawn
a3 might need defense at some moment and
that's why I guess he did it but what
about just work 81 just saying I'm gonna
challenge the D file back how is black
going to make any sort of progress yeah
and I guess the one disadvantage of your
move or say them the movie Giri played
Bishop d4 was that it lost the bishop
here right partly why you were more in
favor of c5 I think both to keep the
bishop here but also to put the kibosh
on c4 which permanently makes that
Bishop on b3 kind of a big pawn
staring at the back of his friend here
so so I'm with you that something maybe
Geary overestimated his potential
advantage with this move Bishop d4
because as I look at the long-term
nature of this position and the moves
you predicted are being played Robert I
also like the fact that now dude is
coming to life he's got the two bishops
feels like Geary let that one get away
you agree totally agreed and he when he
backed up with Queen b6 just a couple
moves ago that's just really bad sign
for him look at this his name is Oh d5 I
think whites are
just rushing I like because if you take
me on d5 let's say with my EEP on now
your ePHI pawn is hanging I'm gonna play
see five I pawn just run forward this
looks absolutely terrible for black Wow
huge huge pawn majority Bishop d4 I
think was a huge miss evaluation by Gary
he doesn't seem too thrilled with it
either dude it continues to kind of look
a little bit sort of like yeah right
well yeah he's just gonna roll those
bonds on the board he's gonna Rick roll
them down
Rick roll him can we get a gift
cuz Duda looks just like the Rick roll
guy remember when we did that in
previous stream we're good we will we
will be we'll be throwing some rick roll
at you look at that he looks just like
right now he looks more than ever what's
the art what's the guy who sings the
rick gastly Rick Astley's Rick really I
mean can we get if Duda wins I'm gonna
ask him to do the Rick roll I can't wait
I wonder if he knows what it is that's
true well if not we'll have to educate
the young man there we go that's it
right there that is my that is my space
that is where I live is doing that just
so you guys want to know what's going on
in my mind all the time it's that that's
going on in my brain constantly okay wow
you wendy6 threatening queen's eggs
juice huge it is Rick rolling him with
the pawns take you c7 he's gonna bring
the bishop up to c3 take f6 and then he
for Falls I love it I love it for white
I think we're about to get a decisive
game for the first time in the match I'm
calling it Duda leads the way with the
first decisive victory here Queen takes
e4 not only guards before but threatens
Queen takes g6 check okay not sure why
he took with the rook I would have gone
for the cheapo that's me he wants to go
rook g4 and threaten she go in two
different ways
he wants to go a little he's going for
the deep cheapo the Depot the Victor
Oladipo Victor Oladipo not to be
confused with finding nepo people asked
what nope omni ah she's name should be I
think finding nepo because some
he needs to find himself with the way he
manages the clock okay now play rook d4
WTF oh my god it's known as why the face
what I told you I love it if you take
you've got the pin yep because that
bishop is pinning upon f7 so Queen takes
g6 will just be a very happy peace to
arrive into the attacked Gary's got the
butter lip going that's the butter lat
meaning he's dejected that's Gary's
disappointed face number two what's
number one when he just literally goes
like this he does this thing you'll
watch him do it today in the Metro go
and you'll shake his head he'll like
back up and kind of shake his head like
he like he knows he messed up
That's Gary number one Gary number two
is yeah wow this is ridiculous Yong
Christophe Duda doesn't go away from his
Italian if you're just joining us he has
played it every time his white failed to
get a victory in the first two affairs
but not that time not that time due to
strikes first and he has a one-game lead
now we get this position that we saw
Magnus play against Bobby yeah really
Magnus is endgame chances but Fabi held
steady yeah and we're referring to the
Sinquefield cup everyone if you want to
look up the game Magnus Carlsen had the
white pieces in this exact line versus
fog in a car wanna know exactly the way
the game with and I feel like during
that game with during the commentary I
was saying how I hate this for black
because it's a two results position for
white right you can only we never draws
white I'm really losing chances and if
you look at this right now right the a
and T pawns are isolated which means
that whenever up comes a c1 it's gonna
direct the attack this pawn on the other
side White's b3 pawn upon it's kind of
sticking out is well defended by another
pawn pawns best friends another pawn so
it's going to be very difficult to
defend this for Duda especially in a
blitz game
Magnus couldn't get too much against
Bobby in a classical game but there's a
lot of time Fabi use it well you found
the resources to hold and hold and we
have the first difference in that game
rook a c1 chosen by a nice
instead of Magnus's rook FC one which
you and I instructed a lot on during
that game saying that Magnus wanted to
keep the rook here to guard the a pawn
against maybe the coming plan of a five
a four by black so this is this is the
first difference in that game nice to
see two very strong grandmasters like
Geary and Duda repeating theory that was
played at the Sinquefield Cup and now
black of course plays the move c6 to try
to eliminate that weakness and head to a
more equal endgame but I agree with you
white will be playing for two results
here for some time to come why it's
already just much better in fact black
is in huge trouble because you can't
take me on d5 is when I take with my
rook on d5 your bishop is pinned
when next week will be rook c7 if you
allow me and very very importantly two
pawns on the Queen side versus one for
black that two-on-one will force Judah's
attention over to the Queen side while
white can operate on both sides of the
board foreshadowed it well and you know
what I love about this is it also it it
tells us that in these speech Chess
Championship matches these guys are
these guys are bringing their a-game
like there's a lot on the line for them
not just the prize money but the pride
and clearly this is this is an event
that they that you know we know that
that's why they play in it but it's just
exciting when you and I look at this
because we're covering the highest
levels of chess the Sinquefield Cup the
grand chest tour over the board
classical games but these guys are not
holding back the fact that they they
always they always want to improve on
modern theory and you know they're going
in for things that they've clearly
prepared right things that they would
play in a main tournament or they
wouldn't have played it here right we
just saw Magnus Carlsen do it is white
yeah exactly are there they're going
with main lines that we've seen MVL
trying to bash his head against the
Berlin many many many times and here
Judas as well it looks good for white I
just simply have an undeveloped on
structure whereas Black has these double
F pawns any endgame is gonna be
favorable how just how favorable remains
to be seen but I'm loving white chances
a free play and an endgame with no risk
where you can move instantly and every
single move Black has to be like wait a
second is why can we create a passed
pawn right play Bishop b4 here and allow
this capture on b6 or does that make
White's journey to a pass one easier so
it's tough questions for black but
I think dad Duda you know down to
minutes not but dude that two minutes in
the clock worst position I'm on the giri
bandwagon right now ya know if he wins
this obviously the match becomes level
once again
of course those just tuning in see that
due to has a one-game lead that actually
just happened in the previous game
winning his white so he makes that
decision that he's gonna allow the
opportunity for the Bishop and pawn
ending it's gonna be hard for black to
hold because you're gonna get one of
these position and he go yeah Gary says
he thinks he has winning chances look
for B for now followed by a four I think
although be for maybe Bishop c2 slows
down the progress so clearly Duda is
gonna work hard to try to slow down the
inevitable on the Queen side but what
makes this vision so hard Robert is not
even just the two-on-one yes white will
forever have the chance of an outside
passer but also f3 opens up king of two
King g3 king h4 and you've got a real
opportunity for two weaknesses to target
here of your Giri here he goes he plays
up for this was an idea we saw Magnus do
against Caruana right you play a four
not even cuz you ever intend to trade
here everyone you don't want to undo the
pawn here in these structures is you
just you just make these pawns stuck so
now black can't try to use the the two
pawns together because pushing up five
loses this guy if you take your as black
you're always creating more problems for
yourself by isolating your double deaf
pawns so this is um I don't know with a
two-minute time advantage a much better
endgame technique I think Gary's gonna
get this one and level the match and we
see him that was almost Geary number
dejected number one he's still thinking
about losing that last game yeah and you
know another element to note about this
position is this pawn on f7 is cemented
in its place because of the pollen f6
the double pawns but if white can attack
that pawn it could be difficult for
black to defend it and you to use some
of your resources your king or a bishop
to state thanking the sponsor right now
d3 seems very natural and a big question
always is you know in white go over some
kind of Bishop c4 Bishop trade the
answer is no right now but at someone
when you have to be concerned about that
if you are due to there's the the
content of Bishop raid is generally bad
where the site would double pawns in an
endgame yeah that's a good point and
especially because it's instructive for
everyone watching you always you have to
be considering the exchanges of every
endgame you're trying to convert on so
you know whether it's good or bad for
you whether you play it or not and it's
the time you take to recognize whether a
transition is favorable that will help
you win time pressure sets right when
you're making those critical decisions
so grandmasters like Robert has always
thinking like that evaluating it does
the exchange help winning chances or not
if you put it this way if you could just
take the bishops off the board right
Robert then it's definitely good for
white because now you have the
two-on-one if the bishops could just
come off without changing the structure
you don't want to trade if you're white
and in it and it forces your pawns to
separate because that makes it harder to
get the outside pass pawn that you want
which is why dude is gonna have to deal
with that now Gary's not gonna not gonna
trade bishops until he gets himself a
past a pawn here yeah one of the things
to also keep an eye on is white playing
g4 h4 and if I get g4 on age 4 then if
you're King the black King goes away
from the e5 pawn at some woman I could
probably take on e5 and if you take with
the pawn on e5 I play like g5 h5 there's
Dark Age pawn down the board yeah I know
it's very deep and that's far away off
but somebody keep in mind is how to
create past pawns for yourself oh it's
principle to weaknesses so it's not that
deep in the sense that okay that's a
very important technical idea that
people should should use when they're
converting advantages don't just beat
your head quickly on one side of the
board use the weaknesses on both sides I
love that idea Robert because it means
that white White's King for example can
never commit you can't fully commit to
helping here because you may have this G
and H pawn right if you if you stay in
the center Black's gonna have to have to
deal with the a pawn with just the
bishop which is gonna be very difficult
so we see a lot of people in chat saying
nah don't underestimate his rap name a
nice giri known as 50% he's gonna draw
this but I don't think so I think in
each gear he's gonna he's gonna show
that he's the the former formerly known
as the artist formerly known as the
artist that you all master I do love
Luis JC 30 saying do two resigns here to
get in Gary's head
and then I want to see someone do that
one time resign and then like at the
next start of the game look directly in
the camera and then resign again just
like be like yo now what it like ever
freaks out like speaking of now this is
Bishop f3 should end the game on the
spot yeah Bishop a3 will force the
exchange as we said the bishop trade
didn't want to happen earlier when
Robert highlighted it because it would
it was taking away why it's opportunity
to convert you wouldn't get the past
pond but once the past ponds created
that's why you take the time to
recognize those things Roberts talking
about cuz now you're like hey I can just
get the bishops off the board now its
winning and in indeed Geary sees it he
plays Bishop of three I think we're
about to have a tide match this time we
get there with with each side trading
trading punches rather than trading like
Pat's on the back instead of trading
drawers like a robot you're doing great
right it's like oh yeah right yeah all
right I just want like full Jason
Statham I and you know it's hard for me
to ignore you completely because I am
your co-host but have to respond right
but you know I don't want respect you've
loved Jason Statham don't you go full
transporter on me just your milk I'll go
full snatch on you oh oh and we're not
doing this right now oh really
Apple me machine on you how's that feel
oh you did it you all go uh spy I mean
that's a week come on that's a great
have you ever seen that movie tell where
is Jason Statham is hilarious in that
movie we don't want to get me J instead
okay all right h4 h5 the King just sits
tight eventually black runs out of moves
and white wins the King and pawn ending
we've seen this story before and that's
what's about to happen
surprise dude is playing it on you think
Duda has a strategy of getting to faster
time controls okay well I don't know I
don't know why he even played that one
on for a long time let's back up and
show the educational element of that
just to remind everybody of why this is
easily lost starting with the transition
where Robin and I went full Jason
Statham references because we knew that
if the bishops came off the board it's a
lost and game
we know that because the outside passer
will force black into a bad opposition
where zoogs Wang happens remember zoogs
Wang is when you have to move if you had
the ability to say pass the game is a
draw so zoogs Wang literally translates
to move compulsion right move discussed
almost because if you could just say
pass there are a lot of chess positions
that actually wouldn't be losing black
would just pass and white could play
tickle but black would never have to
relieve defense the fact that eventually
black has to move when he doesn't want
to he could have wasted one more move
but it doesn't matter eventually black
has to move when he doesn't want to and
white just wins the extra pawn so again
if you're if you're wondering how about
who that how that is what it is move
compulsion looks wrong there you go King
upon endings are a good example of it I
just have Jason Statham movies in my
head right now that's really bad I'm
trying to because you know what we have
on the board right now the Italian Job
or so many straight games when dude is
white ok the Italian job is okay if you
want to go Mark Wahlberg I will
transition with you all night I'm just
trying to find my Transpo huh
ok if you want to go this way I'm just
trying to protect my daughter
I found a transformer in the front yard
my name is Mark Wahlberg sometimes I
have to hide my Boston accent I mean I
just found a transformer in the front
yard ever since my dad you've been
barking at me every day we're back to
the Italian what's going on here why
does root beer make you burp I don't
know Jerry I'm just trying to find a
transformer in the front yard well why
are you trying to find transformers the
movies are horrible Michael Bay puts
branding everywhere I know Jerry but I
need the gigs all right I've been
playing polka I develop a gambling
problem ever since mom died and I'm
doing my best here just trying to
protect my daughter sorry that was Mark
Wahlberg versus Jerry Seinfeld there are
not enough words how much I didn't lie
that experience alright you know what I
do like talking about chess and pawn
structures believe it or not we're back
in the Italian where I think we agreed
that eventually due to got the best of
Giri here in this line it just took some
out playing over time but notice the
Giri has played the a5 extension which
slows down before this is a totally
different Italian than what we saw in
Game one if you're just joining us due
to eventually had a very big space
advantage because b4 b5 happened
probably should have won that game
according to me and Robert eventually
was a draw here this is this is some
different elements Robert what do you
see when you look at this one ice well
Ruby eight is move it you don't really
want to play if you're black because it
feels it's a very defensive move and it
is literally defined pawn on b7 but what
black does have going for them is this
King side I don't call it pressure but
the potential as look this pond g3 h4
over extension on White's King side
which means that if white doesn't you
kind of break through with this
initiative black will play h6 Michael
probably put the Queen on f7 maybe they
work back to f8 and try to break through
on the King side where it does seem like
White has been vulnerable it's funny how
these work though because we've seen
this a few times now where you know
Black has all the potential of threats
you have the F file you have the knight
constantly looking at squares like f4
and and g3 and there's all kinds of
tactics here but with best play it's
very often just that it's the threat
it's the potential of tactics without
really any any execution and I'm I don't
know the more I look at a lot of these
Italians we've looked at so many it
feels over the last month with our grand
chester coverage this opening very
popular even in the slowest time
controls the more i'm coming around that
i don't maybe white can play this kind
of position even in blitz despite the
king being constantly under the threat
of what's going on over here on the
kingside i'm starting to come around to
my long-term positional advantages is
white especially if i can work at queen
c4 no diggity with b4 b5 i don't know
i'm i don't I'm uh I'm coming around to
feeling feeling White's flow here a
little bit more okay I mean I think it
really comes down to a matter of taste
these positions are
chances from both sides you have double
edged to have a position I tend to
merely because I played the Italian as
black so many times and I've always
enjoyed it I think it's very fighting
opening despite the fact that no pawns
are traded it does give both sides right
interesting play and here already you
know I'm thinking is black can I play a
move like Queen h5 then play g5 next
just to attack the white set up
anybody's King h8 to avoid any checks in
the e6 square any pins of that nature
but I do prefer a black I just feel like
King safety favors black just because
even though white isn't so loose in a
practical setting you most the time
you'd be right right but you know one of
the issues is if you go full you try to
go full pry me open right then
eventually maybe your King becomes the
weaker the weaker one on the board so
the main reason I like Gary so far as he
seems to have a better feel for the
positions on the clock the first game we
saw Gary was up almost three minutes at
one point if you're just joining us in
Game one here he's up almost a full
minute and Duda doesn't quite know what
he wants to do with his ponies here
right little pony play Roberts favorite
thing to do on the weekends I'm so upset
at you right now
you know you you know I'm your biggest
fan but most people don't even know what
Pony Play is and no one's gonna Google
it to find out right now you such a
provocateur you know that Alright b5
this is risk it to get the biscuit chess
white is gonna be the one with more
access on the Queen side why do you play
b5 what if I just take and play Queen a4
what's the okay you take Queen eight for
every my other rook over to b8 then I
bring my knight to c5 and I'm gaining
quick momentum on that Queen side and
also mentions B to pawn it's very very
weak okay and probably just lost in that
position
okay interesting all right so he doesn't
trade he puts either 9:03 and i i legit
don't know what dude is doing with the
Knights we do like some sort of instant
replay he's if we back up over here over
the last several moves these Knights
have had a bit of an identity crisis
we've got the Knights REE maneuvering
themselves to worse square slowly but
surely
eventually right back to kind of where
they started and look at gear he's like
all right boy you're fiddling around
with your Knights over here I'm gonna
I'm gonna get some space on the
queenside
all right you convinced me I like black
now moving forward I'm allowed to change
my mind well your mind has been changed
because white had what seemed like a
good promising attempt at play and now
all of a sudden white just backed up and
black gained space by his an open
defiled I've rook on v8 which was
sitting passively defending to b7 pawn
now is on b2 threatening the F to square
so it does feel like everything has gone
correct for a giri and everything's gone
wrong for a Duda and look at the clock
situation yeah once more you know we
keep pointing to this an extra minute on
the clock for Geary so in this moment he
could sit and think you know how exactly
do I want to press forward here before
pawn vulnerable the f2 point already
under attack the a4 pond requires in
defense of the Queen on d1 how is white
going to attack blacks pawns well
keeping the tension alive on d4 and d5
think that's beneficial for white
because black doesn't particularly want
to take on d4 but probably will have to
because otherwise my Knights are kind of
stuck on b7
yeah but so are White's Knight stuck
right so I mean I'm with you it feels
like black is in control here maybe
he'll take on d4 when he's you know darn
good and ready but this definitely
turned around it's an interesting
storyline to the game actually for bring
up the analysis board Ned the more I've
you've talked about this honestly the
more I've learned from you in these
positions honestly and I think if we go
back to the fact that if you want to
look at this match everyone if you're
just joining us game 1 was the same type
of line but you'll note that Geary
allowed white to do the more traditional
plan of b4 and b5 in this game Geary
didn't miss his opportunity to play the
move a5 and really slow down White's
queenside play so after that we got very
similar storylines that we had in the
game 1 if you want to look at it as far
as the the theme of what both sides are
trying to do but just a different
scenario occurs with blacks seemingly
controlling both sides of the board and
ultimately getting what we're seeing
here right the queenside space open up
and ultimately in a live position where
whites in trouble how do you guard a
four and E 4 at the same time Robert
well tactically white has done so
because we take on a for their queen b5
or queen c4 ideas that's why which is
why he took on d4 first and now is the
place as a knight on b4 and the night
before is protected it's more advanced
and it also says to the Queen honey -
well how are you gonna defend a4 and eat
for as you just asked at the same time
yeah the only way to do it is Queen c2
knell to guard both squares and Hey haha
my night just shook the Dikembe Mutombo
thing or not in my house you're not
going to see to anytime soon that's why
night before it just feels right it's
protected a good square and now can I
just
okay I don't even wanna scoop off a for
just say I want to okay you go he goes
out of his way to do with the lady but I
want that pawn yeah but you also don't
want to give away any like Queen be my
stuff yeah yeah that would have been the
idea right you don't want to give white
some sort of counter play well now I can
just take it right and give it to me
baby
well but h5 is a good idea to go to
night h4 night g6 but the question is is
anything more than just a well placed
night or are you launching a pretty good
attack I don't see an attack especially
because of Queens on the 8th and there
wasn't on the board but I think maybe
black we tied down to the back rank
defense and that's an unfortunate place
to be
he's pushing the a pawn and could we see
two victories in a row for Geary to
bounce back from the first loss yet I
mean this is it's getting tougher for
due to here time pressure favors Gary at
least at least in the moment yeah bring
the knight to f6 right now there it is
h5 and E for both weak and you don't
want to push your EEP on because freeze
of many of these light squares may I
just take on h5 I think you need your
nights hanging but yeah it's a trade
night h5 Queen B for Queen g6 we back 66
he didn't carry he leans back as I said
Gary number one where you shake your
head he knows he messed up oh he must
have so bad we didn't see it he's
laughing
but Judah doesn't see it how did he not
see that my god
Judah misses a win of a piece and Gary
just like you see him lenience like
thank you
Thank You Judah Wow it's funny because
what a crazy moment you know a day that
one thing commentary is done is we look
out for all these cheapos at all times
right I saw it's immediately I'll just
like take that night there's the e7
spike gosh
if Geary went to this game talk about
getting by with just by the very few
hairs on his chinny chin chin he likes
to keep it shaved and take on h5 now
okay he dissociating oh my gosh but due
to barely didn't lose on time there you
mean I move with a second left okay but
he should still should still have enough
time to hold if indeed it is holdable
he's gonna try not hold well I don't
think it is but again look at Gary's
clock only two seconds second I just
clarify that good eighty-five okay okay
moves the King up but even h5h for ideas
might have been easier yeah you super
full Nigel short yeah this isn't helping
bring the King up kingi station okay now
he goes back to the other idea I think
this idea is safer you can play h4 what
you just playing tickle the game time on
the clock classic theory the artist
formerly known as draw mister mister
draw h4 but yep you can play it when he
repeats one more time it's gonna be a
draw
now h4 there you go he is a sneaky guy
he is but here comes the king here it
comes
h4 falling what Queens e7 tricky cuz g7
is hanging wait what but can you go to
the kingdom punting game no III we G
fortunate game on exclusive king upon
any wins for black because you get King
f3 and III transition oh my gosh and
Duda takes a big breath and says well I
let that one go he doesn't even know
that he missed Queen takes c6 at this
point we're gonna back up on the
analysis board as these guys start the
next game and show you the moment that
had us so far the moment of the match
especially if Giri goes on to win this
is the kind of moment that you think
back on as you definitely got away with
one right here after giri played Knight
to c6 Duda can win on the spot with the
move Queen takes c6 forcing the fork
followed by the win of a night and
ironically actually it's probably sue
not the easiest endgame to win
but certainly white is the only one who
could do so so nice c6 is played giri
instantly shows that he knows he blunder
but Duda doesn't see it instead he backs
up with the night and ultimately Giri
goes on to win this game if this becomes
this becomes a Giri match victory this
is the kind of game that we remember for
a long time
Wow Wow Wow miss opportunity there and a
shocking oversight but both players but
the reason why I think they missed it is
because you well Giri just miss it and
the reason why they do to miss it in
return was because he didn't expect his
opponent a blunder right like you know
he's the okay and he's just playing very
well he's out playing me in this game
and so he made 96 or returned it towards
the kingside yeah all of a sudden like
wait a sec actually just think that
night just psychology of that how hard
is it to keep that's why we that's why
we admire guys that are so resourceful
and persevere when they're losing
because psychologically when you think
you're worse it's so easy to miss those
opportunities right how hard is that to
keep your head in the game it's very
hard because you're just you feel like
you're doing something wrong which you
kind of are and your points out playing
you with every move so you just feel
like the worst player none see only do
you feel like you're playing a bad game
you just like I can't hang with this
person right of course that feeling
subsides quite quickly and you get over
it but Anish was really playing an
excellent game there and when you played
knight c6 like I said as commentator I'm
used to seeing blunders all the time
especially in speeches championships as
a player when does someone blunder Queen
takes you know Queen takes c6 tactic
against yan Christophe Duda nobody does
because I just extremely strong player
if extremely strong player and you don't
expect URI to make that blunder whereas
I expect myself to make this kind of
blunders which is why I see it and when
it happens or you expect your partner to
make those kind of blunders you can say
that's me
we love seeing those do two emotes he
still got fans despite the fact that
he's losing we got Rock and Eagle
yelling for recovery we got our
subscribers using their due to emo thank
you for your subs all the members with
us hear your views your subs
your support at just calm make these
events possible and we appreciate it so
don't don't forget that thank you so
much we don't have Duda and Geary emotes
at the chest TV chat but we do have a
Robert Hesse mode so let Robert see your
love
get that Robert Hesse mode out if you're
a Premium Member over there on chest
calm man I'm so excited for this match
here this is going to be nuts this is
exciting this is I I do feel that as the
time controls get faster do to prove
that he's capable of comebacks against
Alexandra Creek and last year's SCC
right came back in the bullet portion
down to games so we know that the young
man from Poland is capable of keeping
his head in the game remember against
Grichuk last year Robert he basically
trailed in that match the entire way
until bullet when he made the comeback
yep and as I see Sam Copeland saying
it's not a do de SEC win if he doesn't
have to come back but you gotta stop
playing this opening the second time in
a row he's played this he lost that last
end game to Geary right now Bishop takes
765 is good too I think you are you just
winning material here is white I think
you are Gary's got the head Bob going
you know he's feeling frisky
well did you just winced a piece oh no
no wait can you go back can you burn the
analysis for I shall stay I shall stay
for you so Bishop takes d7 Knight 67
rook takes d8 was what you wanted Bishop
takes up I wanted Queen takes f7 check
oh dude he's just mr. crazy wind you
know just is consoling has been doing
his puzzle rush playing some puzzle
battles bro a you get ready for the
chest calm feed a grand Swiss at the
Isle of Man I am I think you are I'm
feeling good and that you know see those
kind of tactics makes me feel good dude
seriously that was just a win on the
spot right there for white and you saw
it cuz you're headed to the Isle of Man
for the feat a chest calm grant Swiss if
anyone tuning in for the first time to
the twitch.tv slash chess channel needs
more reason to follow this is where the
biggest events in the world of chess
happen don't go anywhere else right
here's where you need to be
Robert Hess will be playing in in the UK
on the Isle yeah I love that and the
Isle of Man right now Robert
see that was a sick tactic you spotted
good job you know I won a game somewhat
like that many years ago and it's really
that just that feeling I'm playing Queen
takes up seven check and like back rate
right someone then so now we've had the
knight c6 blunder last game Gary misses
Queen takes f7 this game I don't even
know if he's aware of it he's got them
he's got the shaking head going but yeah
if I didn't see that exact tactic but he
in the position he prepared out more or
less iam and then he's just like I had a
great position now I'm gonna opposite
color Bishop ending it's no winning
chance yeah well they're this is likely
headed for a draw as you said I mean
there's no winning chances a little
harsh at this point maybe it's not so
let's back up the analysis and actually
show everybody then what the missed win
was then because as Robert pointed out
if indeed this is an obstacle Bishop
ending with no winning chances it was
right here that both sides just failed
to calculate the correct trade move
order taking e7 first and then Queen
takes f7 is just lights out if the rook
takes not only do you win your queen
back but you win the rook full for it
why it ends up being up the exchange if
you move the King okay now actually just
lose the Queen for free so it was just
completely winning on the spot Geary
misses it we are likely headed for a
draw because of it if you wanted a drama
you getting it I see what you did there
yeah there mary j blige has nothing on
this show we want the drama in our life
on this show Bishop b4 winds upon no
Brooke c3 says I was kidding you passed
the test
you know I I do enjoy being tested every
now and then well no more drama in my
life was what Mary Jay wanted maybe she
was talking to a nice giri who is known
in many ways as the artist let's remind
everybody a li question because if this
game ends in a draw in all fairness he
could have won earlier so his nickname
the artist because he likes to draw a
lot maybe it is well deserved I believe
we have some responses now from so
Media thanks for getting involved here
we got our own producer nicknames given
to me in chat today the Sultan of stream
the guy who manages not to murder Danny
Boogie Nights poo pity ok gr and Thor
mr. producer I love this community and
they love you are and all right here we
got sefar devar gets a chest Constance I
mean you're asking the question in the
middle of Geary a block chain of drawers
I gotta go with the artist for Geary his
commitment to drawing is respectful it's
on a forever and after love level PS
Arne is the boss great stuff there from
sefar the bad boy of chefs who is that I
can't see the picture close enough to
know Bobby Fischer Bobby Fischer was he
known as the bad boy of chess I didn't
know that I don't think so I think you
might have just given him that nickname
Hector good for you that might get you a
diamond membership later we'll see our
own Sam Copeland
obviously you got to go with the riga
magician he's a big he's a big
sacrificing pieces that are completely
unsound fanned that Sam's level of chess
right there no kidding Sam blow
everybody that's what Mikkel talvez
known for the magician all right well
get us get at us if you want use the
hashtag speech yes hover your mouse over
the twitch player you can vote via the
twitch extension so no excuses only
results time to get involved in the
social media chatter on these shows you
know Danny it looks like young
christophe Duda is listening to some
simon and garfunkel yeah how dark he got
in his room he's just like hello
darkness my old friend I'm ready I'm
ready to go to faster time controls yeah
he's he's wanting to three-minute and
he's about to get it if you're just
tuning in obviously we have a one-game
lead for the man from the Netherlands
but likely this is our last game in the
5-1 portion so we're gonna have a close
affair heading into the treatment of
portion Samko it says hey hey now I
don't make unsound sacrifices I get
destroyed by unsound sacrifice you're
right I'm sorry
my apologies all right okay what's going
on here dooda dooda trying to strike
back plays e5 this was a trump hausky
attack so he changed up the Italian
apparently he agreed with you that he
finally doesn't like the positions he's
been getting on the white side of that
efore classical
putting if you're just joining us this
is the first game where Duda opened up
with a different pawn that being the
queen pawn so that's a quick little
nugget to note about the storyline of
this match we had a trump house key
something that I used to play back when
I was playing on sound openings but
White's got a small edge here probably
not enough for anything special a
centralized Knight can often make up for
a bishop who's good in the open board
the problem is that the hanging pawn
structure meaning c3 is weak definitely
favors black a little bit so roughly
equal but I'll take white just because I
played these Trump house keys so many
times in my career all right and I'll
take an each side here because I really
don't like the hanging pawns I feel like
any end game will be good for for black
if you can imagine the Queen's just off
the board right now black and then play
pawn f6 to kick this Knight out of a 5
and then just start putting up pressure
on the c3 pawn and then maybe in the a
pawn because look at this rook on g3
it's off to the side and so if I can say
get my room to c4 and over to a4 there's
some potential attack on the Queen side
pawns so I think that right now Anish is
in a good position and dude he's down a
point of the match he's probably
figuring out how can I get aggressive
here yeah but he understands that any
kind of queen g4 is meant by f6
simultaneously protecting the pawn on g7
and attacking this knight on but what I
like Queen c1 right silly rabbit tricks
are for kids but the g7 pawn is pin so
you might try to work it over there now
the knight comes to g4 look at he's just
like you're he's just laughing at the
idea that this g7 pawn being pinned
matters kicking the knight out of its
centralized Square all the way back to
e3 rook takes d4 now it takes d4 the
pawn to c3 is pinned and you know what I
see a pawn I grab a pond that's what I
want I want this thing to get messy look
at this this is how you would win though
you got to give the Polish fighter some
credit here right the to rook for Queen
dynamic might be an opportunity outplay
him although normally you and I say a
lot that in these blitz time controls
the Queen just ends up proving her
weight as
time is less on the clock it's very hard
to compete with the with the lady yeah
the Queen is amazing here the Queen can
go to a3 at any moment to attack the
rook on c1 the Pawnee to and when you
typically see in positions with this
kind of imbalance right there's a queen
for - Brooks is actually queen and pawn
for two rooks but the side would be
safer King is off on the side with the
advantage here both Kings are pretty
safe I think the white king is slightly
safer but this extra pawn plays a big
role in this position because we look at
the Queen side ignore the Queen ignore
the two rooks look at that a and B pawns
versus the a pawn for white that extra
pawn the Queen side feels very
advantageous for black and that's why he
went d5 hoping for pawn takes d5 give me
work takes g7 check and so it said do
this thing like get some activity here
otherwise I'm just gonna roll over shout
that fork on the board but again I I
think that even with all that said I
still think this was something worthy of
getting excited about for Duda because
this is the right approach when you were
just getting squeezed the two rooks in
the open board I don't know I get a
feeling he might have good chances to
hold this one you can guard h4 with g3
the two rooks once they get going are
gonna make it very hard for the Queen to
neglect the King safety so the board
becoming this open no longer may favor
the Queen it only kind of favors the
Queen when the rooks can't get
coordinated right if the Queen could do
what you said poke at this side of the
board while threatening to always poke
at this side of the board but something
tells me these rooks are gonna get
coordinated whether it's on an open file
or on one of these ranks over here I'm
with you I think this game is one of
those where once white just connects the
rooks Yummy's the game will probably
peter out yeah I think I think it's
gonna hold a draw I think it was the
right decision by Duda to to not miss
that chance yeah pick on h4 here right I
think he did okay but row 7 the Brooks
come down I mean this is this is gonna
be tough for black to have any winning
chances yeah you just go you're full
lawnmower right yeah yeah he'll the B
and a pawns then hit the G pawn and yeah
considering black is only up to pawns
right now and okay the Queen is for the
two rooks but black has two extra pawns
but those Queen side pawns
not gonna last very long okay well the
Queen comes to e4 I think the rooks
double on the seventh rank and we likely
see maybe even maybe the Queen even
tries to go for a perpetual herself
because you have ideas like Queenie one
Queenie five of course you can try to
take things on f2 whoa the risk of that
by Judah I was not a fan of that because
one of the only ways these things
backfire for the rooks everyone is when
you disconnect them and then they can
never get coordinated again so okay it
may be unlikely to say they'll never get
coordinated again but this is an
interesting spot right because now
you're worried about blunders Queenie
one wins f2 the rooks are on squares
that are potentially vulnerable to the
Queen doing double attacks on the Kings
and rook so obviously sort of giving
what seems like superficial advice I
guess but I think it's the opportunity
that a lot of players maybe maybe
opportunity for them to blunder in their
own games I don't know this is I don't
like rook takes 85 dude like it all also
a draw was offered by Geary and it was
declined Wow and I assume that he
declined it not because he actively did
so he just made a move and that just
said no draw for ya maybe didn't see it
or or AE solid and said no I actually
like the rook so I guess from that
perspective taking with the rook was
saying that white maybe wants more than
a draw
he is down a point so I guess I was
looking at it from the perspective of
wanting white to hold and the rook
coordination was key in that regard but
maybe he wants more look at him he's
going for the whole thing - Brooks -
Brooks can't be dirty yeah white really
can't ever lose this I don't think so
because the King has nowhere to run to
feel King f8 you get checkmate in one
rookie Jade mate I'm sorry the Queen can
block but you lose your queen and if you
go King to g8 back and keep going rook
c8 check orc c7 that can always be the
draw if I want it I think it is a good
decision by buta to keep playing this is
the last game of the five minutes -
troll so it's not like he's wasting time
or wants to get next time second this is
the final game he'll get a break after
this yep you might as well play it out
yep
no I don't I don't think he's just
trying to draw I just disagree with Chad
on that Leon likes chess wonders if half
the chess players in the world play
blitz from their closet assuming Duda is
in a small space
I don't think he's in a small space fun
fact I used to broadcast from a closet
before we had studio that's actually not
a joke but yeah
and and Robert spent a lot of time with
me in that closet thank God we both came
out of the closet right that just it
feels good
any hooters welcome everybody the speech
has championship rolls on don't go
anywhere right after this we have the
3-1 portion in a very very close match
this is gonna be exciting all right
maybe maybe we have the the draw
commencing now proving me wrong but oh
man
we'd love you chat we love you no matter
where you're watching the show from hit
that purple follow button and you'll be
with me and Robert for the rest of our
lives they drew the draw commences the
artist formerly known as a nice giri
holds true to his half symbol the equal
sign equals but he does take a one-game
lead as we head into the three-minute
portion we will be right back with more
speech Chess Championship action in just
a few moments
[Music]
I wanted it so bad and he did it and we
see the chat reacting to the many faces
of the car oh of course we love him so
much and he is really one of the most
expressive entertaining players who
better to help us with our new speeches
championship intro video than the man
himself to to help it get up to speed
Robert let's remind everybody of where
we're at right now we're through the
first time control young Christopher due
to trails by a game but I think this
match is still gonna be very close in
the end let's bring up our odds charts
and remind everybody of how we saw it
Robert the odds say that we thought this
is gonna be close and and it looks like
it's gonna be yeah for sure and this is
a 50/50 matchup between two very very
evenly contested players here I mean I
couldn't pick somebody to win the match
beforehand I still can't because despite
Kyrie's one game lead thus far after the
five-minute portion we know that Duda is
the comeback kid he did it twice in
speech Chess Championships last year and
he beat Kershaw he beat car yakun so
Gary needs to be careful I can't get
overconfident any point in this match
you see them right there at the eight
nine seats respectively 50/50 is the
coin flip let's remind everybody more
specifically of what we saw as we looked
at these two players heading into
today's match as we said they are the
eight in the ninth seed due to made it
all the way to the semi finals last year
and as Robert said he was kind of known
as the comeback kid so now is the time
for holes get faster will he get better
according to our smarter chess match
predictions Geary needed a 2-point lead
in the 5-1 if he was going to hold his
own with Duda and bullet look at look at
that progression a lot of the match
story
suggest as the time controls get faster
our records indicate that Duda becomes
the slight favorite between these two
guys so if that holds up and this goes
down to maybe a one-game victory for
someone like Duda remember this five
minute portion if you're a nice Giri but
who knows of course obviously the SEC
has history we've been doing this for a
few years but every time these guys play
a match we're always super impressed and
they teach us a little bit more about
what super GM's are capable of in blitz
speaking of which Robert it's time for
some more blitz are you excited I'm very
pumped and we keep talking about how
Duda has spent too much time in the
early stages of the 5-minute yep a
segment I think he's gonna be very fast
here this happens in every SEC match it
seems like players that are slow in the
5-minute are lightning quick in quicker
time which was doesn't really make sense
is just what happens and here he's got
to stop playing this if I was his coach
and I talked to him in between you know
the segment's there when his break I
would have said you know Christoph stop
playing this you're getting bad
positions every game and easy for your
opponent I mean this has to stop I agree
you bring up an interesting point we've
always wondered how much these players
consult the advice of maybe friends or
coaches it's one of the cool things
about this match format that's so
different from other events is that it's
almost like tennis in that sense they
have time in between sets they have
opportunities to reflect and think about
how they handle the five minute portion
openings to adjust or not and even get
advice it's completely legal as long as
they're not getting any advice from a
coach or an engine during a game there's
no reason they couldn't even consult an
engine during the break and be like hey
I keep getting this opening and I think
it's good like let me try to see if I
can improve on it right so a lot of
interesting things to think about in
regards to how players may approach the
SEC and let's try remember to talk to
them about that in the interviews after
the match so if you're wondering whether
they did that stick around to the end of
the match and we'll get the players
opinions Robert the thing about this
line is it was played by both Magnus
Carlsen and Fabio Fabio no Caruana at
the Sinquefield cup so even though I
think from a practical point of view I
agree with you it's not the best
position for black maybe it's hard for
these guys because they want to bring
their best chess to the SCC and they
want to play openings they feel they can
play in OTB events maybe
that's why young Christophe isn't going
away from it I just know that I
disrespect the decision I just don't
like it at all I mean you you hear me
Hervey voice it many times
Briggs I've had the white side of
positions of this many times and you
have the isolated pawn well if you look
at that Bishop on g7 that might as well
be a pawn right now and white can say
all right I can play Knight a for
tonight c5 just play against this Bishop
play for control the squares I can
always put my bishop on g3 to attack
your rook on b8 and use them more kind
of open diagonal for my dark square
Bishop I can play Bishop d3 Bishop b1 at
the right moment to say hey maybe I'll
go check meet you on the Kings side and
he started a knight a4 makes perfect
sense to me and now he's gonna plug his
knight on c5 this is just it's just not
fun to have the black side musicians I
agree and again I I obviously drew the
conclusion he feels like if Fabiano's
playing yet these guys are playing very
serious openings in the sec but I agree
that from a practical point of view
especially in blitz this is not a
position you want to just be worse with
black I think
objectively it is sort of solid yes
white slightly better but you have the
knight on d5 right the pawn on d4 is
isolated and and it's one of those
things where black is worse but but
white has to prove it I think that's
better for longer time controls everyone
that's kind of Robert's point it's not a
happy position to play in blitz and as
you said young Christopher was down on
time in the 5 minute portion now because
he's in a bad spot which is why we don't
like this opening from a practical point
of view he's also getting down on time
here if you know if I have the fortune
of playing you know someone like them in
the Isle of Man I would love to get this
position as well it's a dream position
there's no risk your Knights and c5
black has a solid structure with his
knight on d5 as you pointed out and
these pawns are safe for the moment but
white it's just so much more active and
at any moment you can say let me play
Bishop takes d5 to get good night
against Bishop without a useful diagonal
I just can't look at this position and
help being like right is so so much
better yeah I don't disagree so let's
see what Geary comes up with here to
convert on that edge though he's
obviously up a little bit on time but
that's that's twiddling it
just joining us everyone we still have
an hour and a half maybe maybe nearly
two hours total in the show if you count
postgame interviews so stick with us
gonna be an exciting one only a one game
lead right now in a match that many
people feel is really gonna come down to
the wire
all right diamond remember my p2 and the
chess TV chat says Duda should be
playing more three results style chess
he's agreeing with you Robert this is
like a black is hoping to draw style
chess and and due to being down in the
match he needs to be playing more
dynamic stuff as black so so the chat
agrees with you Robert I don't know
that's a good thing that's a rare thing
for you to have anybody disagree with
you I mean I agree with you on these
shows right but along let me just
butcher that I butchered that totally
right it's not always sunshine and
rainbows between us though sometimes we
have to disagree or agree to disagree
yep I I just you know maybe now the
position is okay but so why is it gotten
better for black the pawn on a3 you feel
is an improvement due to the fact that
b4 is kind of weak for white that's your
idea exactly I've disconnected White's
Queen side pawns so then if you go and
try to scoop up a3 I'll probably get
your b4 pawn and and now actually if I
take on c4 and play Queen f5 a queen
might work its way to d5 and trade off
the Queen's and I don't know I think
that black isn't in too much danger
that's kind of why I was pushing back on
you a little bit not because I ever
disagreed that this is bad for black guy
and maybe we'll see where Gary could
have improved but clearly black they're
playing it for some reason where they
feel like despite the optics being so
bad for black he's worse
visually you look at it and the pieces
are cramped the bad bishop on on I ate
what white I guess has to kind of prove
it right and you know Caruana wasn't was
able to hold against Magnus he couldn't
prove it and maybe no dude is like you
know what it's not that bad I'm gonna
play this position as black but looking
to does claw okay I agree he's spending
a lot of time I'm not trying to argue
with you I'm just saying that I agree
with you from a classical standpoint
locate threatening checkmate so yeah oh
queen of five now the Queen just okay
capturing seems reasonable now you've
doubled pawns on the Kings side and
mike is not toast or anything like that
well this thing is these pawns are
potentially weak deform before right
yeah this King can just run to f4 okay
all right I'm feeling a giri giri is in
charge here
yeah and look at the clock it's no good
she's dama no sorry my p2 it's
pronounced meep-meep there you go
it's beep-beep-beep - not my p2 now
watch yourself on granted it's a double
pawn so it's not the best father in the
world the double isolated pawn yeah but
it's a three-on-three on the Kings side
and very importantly there's an extra
pawn over there on the Queen side so
actually I don't really like how yeah
the problem is if you go for a three now
black wins both be for a d4 in exchange
for the one a pond yeah something just
think he's gonna trade everything so
right so you can play brook a7 here the
question is if black even trade into the
night and Bishop ending you would never
want to do that with the past a pawn but
oh wow
keeps up f7 was a decision taking on h5
I was not explained
yeah he's just saying that okay my pawn
structure is better you have the outside
pass bomb but so do I now on the Kings
side right we got H versus a this is in
rosy a for push that pawn over up t3
check my place would have lost the
bishop there by a droopy three back but
yeah it was not a good move okay yeah
yeah Brooke III would have held there
here comes Duda with the active King yep
Oh Bishop e6 you should be six what a
nice anchor bishop protected pawn
protected brookey somewhere comes the H
pawn falling now he's in trouble dude is
in trouble the times of time scramble
was real Oh work takes f2 check as a
threat though oh you exist if he allows
it what check he didn't go for it okay I
use my g4 as maybe superior he fell just
I didn't want to force the rooks off the
board but still now you can play rook F
2 & 2
to get you sorry bishop starting it lol
but he's gonna bring the king in and
checkmate him why not just go for it you
could have played Knight g5 check there
as well and then taking it because it
protect the run the point seven seconds
literally living on the clock right now
we're trying to analyze the chess and
they're just literally in a scramble
Gary's gonna win and take a two-game
lead maybe Judah needs to turn the
lights back off it's the right color
corner over there in a right color
corner for the fish up oh my god let's
let's back up quickly in that game as
the next one gets underway and and show
real quick I think the last moment was
the one I was calling for where he
should have played for the knight g5
idea Robert right here he could have
played Knight g5 and taken east six
because it protects the rook and it's
key because then he has rookie four and
he would have drawn the endgame yep I
agree this was this was the last chance
that he missed to hold Knight g5 check
and take c6 probably just missed that
King g3 doesn't actually win the rook
has the knight can take with the
protection applied so this was huge he
doesn't go Knight g5 check instead 96
and then ultimately blunders the night
here with rookie four because the brook
comes to d5 and the night falls so
wowzer wow sir Mark Wahlberg could go
for some clam chowder well to ride with
Wales or shadow board up I went for it I
thought of a rhyme and I went for it you
know and I can't blame a guy for trying
your lyrics really are bottomless
alright well if you're just getting here
everyone we had the largest lead of the
match these guys started out in a
complete deadlock the first four games
were drawn before Yong Christophe Duda
actually took the first full point but
since then the momentum is shifted
almost like it woke up a nice giri and
right now the Dutchman is up two games
alright this is uh maybe in large part
been to your correct criticism of Dunas
openings because despite the fact that
he kind of held on there I agree that on
a practical perspective from a practical
point of view he took a lot of time on
the clock to hold on
he just yeah he was down two seconds and
he end up blundering in a position that
he held he really was doing a great job
at a certain point I think that's really
to point out the Giri is the one who
butchered what look like a great
position but I just I can't stand seeing
an opening again and it's not like it's
the worst thing I've ever seen you
played in a classical game sure I just
do not think it's the right opening for
blitz and it's gonna keep fighting Duda
because he keeps spending so much time
to try to make sure he's not totally
busted very early and then he has to
fight back and have no space and not for
me
Anish Gary offered a draw in this game
no no yes a nice giri offered the draw
and young Chris of Judah declined it all
those we look at the board the obstacle
Bishop bending doesn't offer a ton of
winning chances for either side so does
that mean Duda wants the clock to drain
to get to bullit and he's happy to play
this one on it's a question of whether
he feels he's the favorite in the
fastest time control against a nice giri
we see there obviously the Dutchman who
is flying that's right up two games
right now in the match he's he's number
one in the Netherlands number four in
the world number one in your hearts too
many people here on Twitch so a nice
giri right now a few games and I think
Duda does want bullit it's where he made
the comeback against sasha grey shocked
last year Robert I think Duda wants to
get that that clock you see right there
the 48 minutes remaining I think he
wants that thing to drain and get to
bullit
oh he absolutely does because Anish
would be the first admit that bullet is
his weakest of time segment because he
doesn't played that much bullet and in
fact he was just on a stream several
months ago and i was playing him in a
bunch of bullet games and there's no
increment which makes a big difference
and I think he went only like plus one
against me which is not really a good
sign when you're trying to face off
against a player like John Christophe
Duda who plays a lot of online chest
especially relative to URI well and this
game continuing is just proof that he
has match strategy cuz there's no reason
for him to do this unless he legit
believes that every second out of blitz
is a better chance for him to get to
one-one we
the quote from Duda obviously our own
Peter Dockers and our other journalists
reach out to the players every match
we'd like to give you those pre match
previews and we get interview questions
and due to admitted freely that he feels
like his best chance is in the one one
portion so there you go
mystery solved mystery solved and the
mystery of this opening openings you get
your wig Robert I'm so happy you don't
understand how happy I am how happy are
you I'm ecstatic you can't tell because
I'm still being serious but I'm very
happy and these kind of positions right
look this nighttime before your pawns on
84 so you can't kick my night out which
is important and what black likes to do
typically is at Bishop d7 this should be
c6 and control the d5 square and
oftentimes even if white goes 95 you say
well I don't really care about giving
them the Bishop fare here because like
last game I have a very solid impact
structure I've controlled the d5 square
but very importantly in this position
compared to the ones we were seeing
black is much more active in particular
because it's nighttime before yeah the
night before as you said and they want
the d5 square isolated queen pawn
strategy typically is that you really
want to hold control over the square
directly in front of the pawn preventing
opportunities were often the person with
the pawn will maybe try to thrust d5 and
blow things open for four good tactics
in fact right on cue he actually does it
right in time before black gets Bishop
c6 so that's one of the reasons you try
to go night before in Bishop c6 is
Robert highlighted but a giri was not
just gonna be a witness to this right
not gonna play bystander at the risk of
losing the bishop here however if black
wants to trade everything and and he
does indeed black is gonna be left with
the two bishops and probably the
slightly better in game even on Bishop
c6 if the Queen to trade it so so Geary
they're kind of proving the strategy and
the advice we're giving here Robert
because do two now has the bishop pair
rather than the isolated queen pawn
compensation he had and as the position
opens up we know that will help blacks
blacks chances right and just better
pawn structure for black grants and your
opponent be something's under attack
immediately
but that pawn aid for potential
vulnerability why is he spending so much
I feel like just play Bishop c6 you have
that I guess after trade the knight on
f3 comes to either d4 d5 and what you
don't want is for your Bishop air
advantage to be lost so quickly so he
doesn't want the night to come in and
make a trade for the bishop on c6 but it
seems perfectly reasonable for him to
get there and or maybe he's continuing
with his match strategy knowing that
he's equalized and spending a lot of
time here just to take some time
interesting look at that I think Geary
literally just had that thought the way
you said that
Gary kind of like looks over and he's I
think for the first time was sitting
there wondering why is he taking so much
time and then we see Gary's furrowed
brow when he did when he doesn't agree
with his opponents move there and maybe
he's right maybe he's looking at do too
saying I know you want bullet buddy but
this is a way to make blacks position
worse I'm with Geary on this one that
seems weird I just don't really know how
why he's gonna take advantage of this
because what Judah is realizing is that
if I trade Queens on d8 if you know if
he played Bishop c6 on a b6 as you were
pointing on the bishop would have to
take on d8 and then the white knight
would come after the LightSquared Bishop
but he's playing b6 saying but what you
got now do your work a to d1 your pawn
to a4 seems like it's under attack and I
could probably just take it oh it's a
challenging moment for Geary to find the
right plant afford he's also down on the
clock right now
and so I think Jude is making the right
decision okay interesting
Bishop c7 wowzers we didn't see that
coming
definitely did not see that coming was
distracting the Queen away the Queen
reviews you put rook take c7 and if you
defend the pinned Bishop I think white
can just bring more PP on the pp put
pressure on the pinned piece let's look
at it I think I think after like Queen
c7 bishop c6 to get out just barely
right show me mine I show you yours
right but there's there's clean qi5 in
some of those positions and then the
Queen has to move actually looks like
what we're about to get Queen she fires
away for
for Gary to keep the ladies on the board
so we'll uh we'll keep the analysis
right here okay Queenie five another
thing kind of does the same thing you
protect the rook and if you trade Queens
the night comes in immediately and
suddenly Geary is putting some pressure
on the position yeah you know your queen
e5 so I mean trying to you have to trade
I feel like you sort of do yeah and he
does it
alright so that Bishop considering you
six this is one of those positions that
remind me of certain Catalans obviously
there's no fee and couture Bishop for
white or anything like that but what I
mean is look at the pawn structure for
black on the Queen side
a7 b6 I can take your Bishop off of d5
then my knight goes
prancing into the c6 square and I'm just
like challenging your Queen side asking
you questions you really want to push
your pawn to a6 or a5 not especially but
you might have to
fun fact Robert Knights don't go
prancing only reindeers do so you got
that one wrong buddy alright I won't
hold it against you tonight's busy
popping in to c6 all right rook da
displayed I don't know I mean I
criticize Duda for playing b6 just from
the strategy of not going for the equal
position and I'm sticking by I like
Girish I think gear he's the only one
who can win this so put the rook on the
seventh rank make sure that black knows
you're happy to see him over here I mean
there's legit winning chances rook c7
you play b4 b5 secure c6 and you're
gonna put the night there even if you
can trade because my c6 pawn instantly
becomes super dangerous so nice c6
really want to get my rook out so he got
fate and then move rock out to see it or
something like that instead he puts a 4
ok ok this is 7 they rip d8 yeah and I
guess the main issue ok you play nice e6
and just don't blunder rook D - OH
he plays rook e1 but look out for
checkmate ideas so he could ours it
moves the King freeze let's better
rook d2 black blessing almost winning
what is happened this happened I'm
confused but now of a sudden duties up
upon I don't know what happened there I
loved White's chances the rooks on the
seventh rank in the centralized night
but Duke boy do I feel silly little
sheepish over here you know I was just
thinking about the reindeer coming you
mean and I look back at the board and
all of a sudden black is the one of them
all rule number one don't ever think
about a reindeer what chess is on the
line TC for RB to you bring the king in
next okay but now maybe White's just in
time for a counter play these rook
endings are so weird you have to be
careful White's gonna have three pawns
this is gonna be one of those really fun
races where probably the rook is just
winning you want to just push the H pawn
I think yeah forget the other pawns your
only chance is to draw and I think this
is I feel like this should be hold of
all four white yeah that's my g5 Benjy
oh now you got an f6 that's the point
okay so you put the King on h8 and are
you there just in time still me oh my
God he's still mated you can't play the
rook over oh there's a sick draw doing
shakes his head is that is that a
theoretically holdable Lincoln like
swimming go back okay going pretty sure
who's winning
and this was in this position f6 instead
of king f7 King takes f6 and then after
age seven used for okay four and you
made him oh my god yeah duh and this is
a common idea in these end games where
you you force the King to checkmate
itself by coming to g8 and and I think I
think even King G six wins in this
position because on rook a for you can't
get a queen it would be checkmate so you
end up under promoting you hold alt
never forget that and you under promote
you a knight but after the King moves
you're still in a lost endgame here very
typical just to show the brook comes
back to the G file and you're losing the
night by force in these positions so
this is this is a good little trick to
know because in some cases what Robert
just highlighted of the rooks sliding
over the easiest win is certainly there
but in some cases this idea where you
force them to under promote is a really
important thing to have in your and your
toolkit that this is a forced win when
you bring the rook back you can also
check and do it and then you cut the
communication off between the king and
the night the night has no safe squares
and so you ultimately win it okay well
so at least it led to some inadvertent
analysis that maybe helps everybody here
get better because that was crazy and I
don't know why everyone's like
face-palming for me oh because I held
alt instead of control or control
instead of all just go to my Twitter
page and you'll see the the clippable
moment gone crazy
anyway but yeah that was interesting
that's instructive to see that it was
winning and Geary misses his opportunity
still has a two-game leaving the match
though Robert so how many games have we
had that we feel could have gone the
other way if you're just getting your
everyone to crazy 5-minute games where
both sides missing opportunities to win
blunders on the board Robert and I make
a lot of them so we catch them when they
happen and this this match in many ways
could have a different score right now
but I don't think it's a sign that these
guys aren't playing well I think they've
played well but just in some key moments
have just made huge mistakes yeah yeah I
mean it's been a very close match and
that one giri clearly got away with and
we did I was still shaking his head of
that he's still upset with himself and
he needs to gather himself he needs to
forget about that game I know it's
difficult but right now with the white
piece is he's got a better position look
at the undie for protect it nice and
safe you can play as right here or over
to be one or work to see one I probably
rugby one just because I don't want to
give black control of this open file and
I worked at b5 come to easily but work
out b1 is the move that I'd probably
play here
speaking of openings we've seen played
from top level chess efficiently this is
just like the game where Aronian was
black and played for the rook b5 idea to
target the a5 pawn yep
a game that eventually didn't go well
for him right versus Dingley Wren am I
remembering that correctly no he won the
game in black are you sure yeah and
wasn't it was against yeah I don't
remember I remember but Aronian won that
game with black there was there was a
game that turned around against someone
like anyway focusing in the moment here
black does eventually execute the idea
that Aronian did where the a pawn Falls
the whole point though is that we
remember talking a lot about this theory
White's gonna move the bishop and that
means the knight is sort of frozen on a
5 because the a6 pawn Falls and a lot of
lines so this position is not so clear
at all just because Black has won the
800 we talked a lot about this there's
ideas where you can take now you can
double on the a file okay you do this
way I was gonna say Brooke a4 and then
over but this has the same idea you're
threatening to double on the a file and
just win your material back so this is
this is a line we've actually been again
seeing these two guys not afraid to go
into topical Theory they're playing some
very high-level chess here one of the
reasons why we get mark Crowther at Twix
often he reaches out to us and wants the
PGN files from the speeches championship
because he knows these guys are playing
real openings and it's valuable PGN
downloads for professionals so this is
uh interest interesting stuff I'm not I
gotta remember the game we were talking
about I know Aronian won the game
against Fabiano but I feel like we also
saw a game where this plan really
backfired for black and I'm just I'm
liking do disposition here yeah I mean
blacks pieces are all tied to each other
right the pawn a6 is hanging beyond the
knight on a5 boots at b3 makes sense and
wait you can't go rook a1 to a2 because
night c1 comes at the fort so you have
to play Brooke a4 here only move
actually yeah but the point everyone is
that black couldn't take on g5 the last
move because Knight takes threatens
Queen h7 and if
play g6e sixes lights out and white is
just blowing open the kingside so
instead we saw knight b3 who he goes for
it he plays queen if I forget the rook
on a1 he wants the attack I like I like
taking h6 just do it go for it we just
take the knight first I like your ideas
taken I remove the Queen from retreating
Robert
you dirty dog you're so brilliant Oh a
place where K Ford did he miss it
rook takes takes and takes h6 the point
is if you do something you get mated
because the Queen lacks the retreating
square look at Robert Hess well you set
me up I just you know I spiked down like
I give you the assist and then I'm like
the Steve Nash to your Amar'e Stoudemire
I knew where rex spax playing basketball
as you know so it works that checks out
yeah Eric Hanson still talking crap by
the way about playing US basketball
we're gonna crush them and two and two
cameras got nothing on us and wait I
love the way White is playing this
though and again Rob and I obviously had
some confusion or just not a debate but
we were remembering that we've seen this
line being played it's very topical
right now but this is an example of how
it backfires for black when you take
that a 5-pound you're then struggling
for coordination for the rest of game
90s d4 I don't think so there's Queen
upsy-daisy for the free pawn oh my gosh
wait missed it he missed it again 19 c4
was a free pawn analyzing now looks
terrible Queen h4 at least to me oh my
gosh maybe Gary okay I think White's
still had why didn't have to take back
but yeah this is definitely much better
for white now Wow white just crushing
through here the f7 pawn is falling
there's also threats now of 96 and a lot
of positions because of f8 hanging like
honestly if you play rook d7 I think
white just plays Pawnee six so Gary
tries to come up with something else but
it's just likely too little too late
wait but this this is all he got he had
to played with the night because if you
take with the rook King g8 and
everybody's hanging what in the world
would what just happened what he lost on
time
though he but he blundered and then he
I'm so confused
let's go back and take a quick look he's
tilting he's tilting dude is tilting in
this position white was in control
where did he oh he was already
blundering because 92 and the rook is
trapped but I understand all captures on
f7 right there was no reason to do it
didn't feel necessarily or if he's Ginty
gonna have something sticking with a
knight first I just like checkmate yeah
it's a great point by the way everyone
black isn't even threatening to take
here because white takes with the pawn
which is a fork of the king and queen so
Roberts completely right just take with
the knight actually and then Queen h6 is
just made oh my god in no time dude it
is just tilting right now that was it
that was an easy win there for white Wow
three game lead for a nice giri but
don't turn your back on the man from
poland it's not a victory unless it's a
comeback victory someone someone said it
in twitch chat earlier and i'm stealing
it
they don't call it a comeback dude has
been here for years since this is what
he does but still right now it's not
looking not looking like some
high-quality chess clearly he's a little
frustrated you can see visibly a nice
giri is zoned in yeah dude it took off
the headphone so you know that he's
really ready to play now because the
headsets off whatever music he was
listening to without the window and he
needs to he needs to write this he
cannot lose this game oh he's got run
out of the black side of this change
slob slightly better for white but
nothing too serious
actually I leave enough White's better I
usually think that White's better in
every opening but right now it looks
like nothing you spoke spoke based on
previous experiences where you'd
normally be right but yeah this is
probably fine for black but again the
main thing right now is the
psychological edge that Gary possesses
having a three game lead and it's the
way he's getting it right due to had no
business losing that game but he did
yeah when you're from a potential
one-game deficit to a 3-game deficit all
of a sudden you know it's not
insurmountable of course he is the
comeback kid but it feels terrible
yep 29 minutes left here in the 3 minute
portion before bullet commences it solid
position and very solid position for
both challenging on the C file and okay
I mean Black has been well there's 96
bring the 9 to c4 be happy don't worry
be happy
yeah he's kind of simple here for both
sides Cheers my hand shakes I thought
maybe he would just maintain the
pressure on the seat fall 22 now he's
conceited it's temporary but still the
only open file belongs to black right
now yep though I still believe in
bringing his knight in to c4 it feels
like the 97's the piece it's not doing
much I do like what he just did on the
Kings side gained some space over there
but bringing this night
so maybe Queen c7 to really control the
C file than 96 better bring this night
in to c4 it feels right I like it I like
it I love it I want some more of it
white is so passive here so so passive
you drive rook c12 you know offer an
exchange of rooks but even that doesn't
solve all your problems because you're 9
and a 2 is much worse than item B 6 is
coming to see for the bishop on e7 is
clearly bad the bish 1f to the bishop on
f2 is just kind of sitting there the
bishop on e7 controlling scores on both
diagonals and maybe g5 just keep to h4
pawn protected is an idea but I would
worry if I ever played g5 for black f4
for white yeah feels like a 32 and then
you never have a chance to play Chi 5
again ok Gary on the defensive here but
again will it be enough the structure is
being so symmetrical you could have
changed the structure just there if he
took at the pollen c6 instead of the
Queen I don't know if that was better
but
you know as if in terms of winning
chances trying to make that trade might
have been oh yes okay but that means
white has ceded to control of all these
light squares in particularly the e4
square yeah but you've also got the
potential of your idea where the night
comes around to f3 and h4 might be the
easiest target on the board here it
comes in 95 now yeah we're going to I
that's the other way to get there both
routes may lead to f3 95 hits the point
of 7c actually getting tempo but I guess
you know if I keep mine there now 5 how
you actually in a windy poem h4 yeah so
you put the knight on f3 to make blacks
pieces frozen ooh wait he's played f6 to
get g5 he doesn't wanna be doesn't want
to be Elsa no frozen for this guy and a
g6 no just you win the pawn age 4 for
free oh he still takes his head yeah oMG
xur snaps that was a blunder what was
that doing Wow
okay probably this could still be a draw
but that was not what he intended there
oh my gosh
he's so upset with himself he should be
that was just there's no need to play
off 6 well that's why we weren't even
considering it I was like f6 he doesn't
want to sit tight but it turns out he
should've speak for yourself I didn't
consider it has been final Tony never
play f6 oh well that makes one of us who
listens to anything that comes out of
Ben's mouth they don't so at least you
still got somebody the the move g5 kind
of closes up and kind of offers a draw
here almost I don't think so h4 h5 is
one idea and the bishop on c7 is so weak
that perhaps at the right moment I'll
put it this way why was there a point in
playing g5 couldn't wasn't there other
ways to be more flexible you could play
h4 with the tension and if they ever
take g4 you get the king in when you're
you're stuck actually yeah you're in
zoos Ondina him over oh my gosh bishop
da black is just busted yeah the whole
time black was lost the thing
Wow there was no way to hold it so Gary
plays g5 to threaten h5 - weaknesses on
both sides of the board that's why you
don't want your pawns locked on the same
color as the enemy Bishop Gary taking
his time
now he's gonna give up the H pawn to
make sure he can hold the e pawn I think
yep Bishop e1 check he'll play king of
three black will take but White gets b6
and with it a much better oh my god what
a strong move King E - lets show why
look at this everyone if you take b6
right away Black gets Bishop e1 and even
though White's likely still winning
you have to rebrand the blockade he
patiently lets the b-pawn sit in agony
just to stop the bishop from getting any
Avenue to return King e2 is a super
precise move take note that's
Grandmaster technique the move King e2
and now everybody falls on the Queen
side as you can see on the live board
white already has the past a pawn and
it's over that is that was impressive
it's clear a niche didn't like the
nickname that you gave him with the half
symbol the half simple the the artist
formerly known as as Prince a nice giri
is the artist formerly known as the half
symbol but we do have more reactions
regarding the daily question if you're
just joining the show and wondering what
that reference is all about we the the
question I'll just say it verbally was
who has the best nickname in chess you
can get involved via the hash tag speech
chess and engaged with chest outcomes
Twitter account josé raúl capablanca x'
prowess accuracy and the speed of his
play earned him the nickname the human
chess machine so there you go have a
blanket wasn't even one that we brought
up earlier sasha is more of a Russian
nickname just for Alexander so even
though I think that's a useful and good
nickname I and that's a great picture of
him but I don't know that that really
counts as a chess nickname so
unfortunately for Dean we're not gonna
give you that one Lannie
Ranen says the chest night for Richard
ready for his night opening I've played
hundred games of it with it on chess
calm and really enjoyed this experience
okay that's a great one that's and it's
not one that we had obviously the famous
ones the beast from baku that's Kasparov
Riga magician Mikkel
towel Mozart of chess magnus carlsen
there are many but you know the Czech
night it's interesting yeah that's a
good one we didn't have that one there
you go
get involved you can hold your mouse
over the twitch player and vote via the
extension right on twitch if you're not
into the whole social media hashtag
speech s thing if you're on chest comm
TV let us know in the chat or as we said
get involved with it with the hashtag
yeah actually there's another good one
that I had mentioned earlier for sibian
Fuhrman who was Anatoly Karpov strainer
his nickname is the walking SEO because
he knew all the openings on cyclope s
openings
Miep to Diamond remember chess TV chat
says we need a nickname for Dingley run
okay well think about it King ding kind
of like LeBron James the King King ding
that might be appropriate if if ding
eventually becomes world champion Sergei
karak and the Minister of Defense that's
when we'd even list of course that's
when we use all the time right that's a
great one all right well right now we
have a four-game lead we're kind of
surprised honestly if you're here this
has been a super close match on the
board but somehow Gary pulling away I
don't want to say Yonkers stop beating
himself to take away any credit for a
niche but there's definitely been some
moments here where it feels like young
Christoph's on a bit of kilt robert
would you agree yeah but Annie she's
getting crushed in this game so at least
if yon Christoph can convert this which
he should then he is gonna be right back
in this match who needs to win I mean he
just has a wonderful position look at
blacks King stuck in the center if you
play Bishop takes e5 English go Queen
takes e4 and say okay your best to move
again I'm against the d6 square well
that's what happened right he takes e5
but Queen takes c4 and the main point
you're saying is the bishop moves I pop
a pony into d6 and you lose the right to
castle you can also click Queen c3 here
as well if you want now you're talking I
liked Queen c3 he doesn't go for Bishop
takes c4 inadvertently also threatens
the
here everyone because there's a pet
potential discoveries now Queen c3 comes
with tempo oh gosh this is what gears
vanitas face just like what just
happened and dude is just you know he's
got to collect himself this is his game
right now yes you just gotta he's got a
strike here
yeah because Bishop before you just ate
with the rook on d4 and you're able to
offer actually take with the pawn and
then by de d5 it just as good right so
the point here everyone is the queen is
hitting the rook with tempo as well as a
double threat to put a knight on f6 and
the tactic the Robert just highlighted
Bishop d4 cutting off communication
doesn't work for a number of reasons one
of them being you can take and then
renew a double attack with the rook on
h8 and the knight on c6 simultaneously
coming under fire rook takes d4 is also
a fun move to play because if takes you
can at the very least just win a pawn
and renew the discovery but I think
Roberts right that Bishop d4 will be met
by e takes which means right now
especially as you look at the clock dude
is about to strike back right yep he's
got this game that's for sure he's about
to say dude dude where's my car
where's my win about to get him comes
eat tasty here comes d5 you push him
baby put the king gonna be 1 it doesn't
help black kicks just blow it open so
many good moves here for white take with
the bishop this King is stuck forever
more in the center yep it looks like the
Polish fighter right which also sounds
like a great boxing name if that ends up
becoming his nickname to put the Polish
fighter then you know well deserved do I
have Queen c7 and rook d6 come on Robert
tell me I dunno I didn't the King would
have more than five which looks crazy
I'm not saying I didn't want to go for
it but apparently it didn't work yeah
because now he was Queen before check he
scoops up the e4 pawn the bishop you
take P seven bishop takes now d6 and b7
both under fire I think that Gary should
resign here because it's been going so
well in blitz why spend more time here
right Knight say get another game trying
to rack up another W and he agrees so
Duda strikes back officially now this
say a four-game lead that Geary once had
down to three we had the first ever
four-game lead overcome by the way by
Maxine boshy that got at least in the
main SEC in the in the main the biggest
event we do here
the biggest event really in online chess
we've been doing now for a few years we
had never seen a four-game comeback
comeback to a victory but Maxine Boucher
Rob did it again sway ye earlier this
week that was really crazy that was a
weird start right I mean like MDL was
not there and then suddenly it was over
just a landslide MBL just destroyed him
you know I love the song landslide so
you just said the word name like Steve I
want you to start thinking about Stevie
Nicks all I got to do is slide into the
DMS hit you with a landslide reference
Bishop d3 coming here we go
h7 was under fire Black has to play a
five don't kid yourself that's not a
move you happy you're happy about that's
not in your happy place although you're
gonna be happy when you play c5 yeah
that is a happiness idea when it comes
to the Carroll Slav structure of this
pawn structure where Black is worse on a
spacial level but if you can break
through and change it you provide
liberation to the light square Bishop
almost always and now it's so bad that
white wants to justify d5 and he plays
it right as I highlight it we want to
trade it to try to open things up but
something tells me blacks should be fine
as long as the Queen's come off the
board and we don't get some line like
this where were white ends up getting
the attack that he wants then black
should be fine here yeah because blacks
pieces just come to life you can trade
Queens on h4 and then play 95 for
example and just like a g6 also makes
sense but 95 was a way to keep the
pieces going keep the initiative up and
play aggressively so he's gonna have to
take with the rook wait unless he has
Knight f8 maybe he wants Knight if a
coordinate so that you don't have to
worry about pressure on the d6 Bishop
actually kind of like that be a little
more patient actually makes a lot of
sense you know what's crazy dude well I
thought there might be a line like
Knight f8 Bishop f5 takes takes and
maybe I have like these checkmate ideas
with Knight h6 but ok it didn't work you
love going for an unsound checkmate hey
that's why they called me in high school
they called me
he who sacrifices with no purpose that's
really long yeah it was also my
spiritual Native American name being
kevin costner he danced with Wolves I
sacrificed with no purpose so there you
go
oh here comes sacrifice oh but this one
has purpose I think because now that the
G files open and the d6 ship is under
fire there's threats of Bishop e6 check
cutting on education yeah issues hanging
in there so with the Knights pin this is
this has purpose here okay so what are
you doing Bishop c6 just defend the
night
how does white continue this after
Bishop c6 I'm okay he goes Bishop f4 cuz
he's threatening rook h1 but I have to
believe that Gary's gonna get the
material back okay he takes the 8th he
allows the check because at least the
bishop prevents the other rook from
checking on the open file I don't know
dude I like the sac I like the way
Gary's playing he likes it we see him
lift the lower lip like that's what goes
on his head when he does that he goes
before didn't make sense to me
Bishop c6 protecting that Knight looked
a lot more natural this is getting too
fancy and you're getting going for
tactical saves but bishop c6 protected
the piece that was under attack
it was g3 there still I mean understand
this was never gonna be that easy for
black well I'm gonna same black was
winning I just don't this looks bad from
black ya know now I'm now I'm with you I
agree and it definitely feels like Geary
is in control this would not be the way
you want to see the three-minute segment
come to an end but as we said he's doing
better in blitz so you know Geary Geary
needs to get as many w's as he can given
that a lot of us look at polish fighter
as the favorite and bullet and probably
you probably even Geary would say that
will obviously ask him after the match
but white Sanderson pawn though Judah
needs to wake up right I know he's super
young is it legal to have coffee when
you're that age how old is he 12 you
know he's a at least 12 21 that was just
a cue for you to drink some coffee
maybe bingo
okay black gonna have to hold now down
upon without any other kind of dynamic
targets though it feels like it's just a
matter of time but probably you want to
do here
Robert correct me if I'm wrong but
trading off one of the pairs of Bishops
like maybe the LightSquared Bishop
probably makes your job easier if you're
trying to convert right you don't want
the black bishops to be able to set up a
blockade so what would you do here as
the as the resident Grandmaster how do
you convert on this extra pawn advantage
for everyone watching to take notes
yeah definite Art here behind King D III
and as you said you just want to get
into a position where you can offer some
exchanges in a very useful you're a king
d2 similar right
there's no Bishop c2 and so I've enjoyed
about that getting an exchange of
Bishops helps right it should help but
I'm a little concerned that black is so
active here yeah maybe doesn't make a
difference and white is just going to
press for it but the activity of blacks
King and different that the a8 square is
the Michael I always keep an eye on
those things you know the aide square
wrong color yeah black knows what he
needs to do braid off White's B and C
pawns or blacks all three of blacks
Queen side pawns and then sacrifice the
bishop in the H bomb for the F and G run
the king of the corner it is a very long
way to get there it is not something
that I think will happen but something I
will always keep in the back of my mind
yeah he keeps having an active King
that's a good point so Gary has to
relocate in order to slowly push him
back what's the ring that came back to
d3
you'd love to find a way to actually
give up both these pawns for blacks H
pawn if it ends up leading to it to a
run of the King King II for King d5 King
c6 came b7 so that's why I dude is
thinking here cuz here comes ideas where
were white sacrifices both King side
pawns to open up the King run right but
again now g4 champion thanks because
it's under attack there he game to tempo
yeah this is a huge moment and that idea
of
I seen the kingside to use that extra
pawn as a decoy is gonna net giri the w
here man
here he goes the king runs and those
well the super smart idea but also just
very well timed make sure that bishop
would be under attack once the King
reach d5 now we can even play Bishop F
to first if he wants play the King to d5
take on c5 patiently wait for which
passed pawn to explode on look at that
Bishop f2 man I'm guessing these
technical moves right look at me Robert
you're you're on it right now thanks
buddy join you the respect you deserve
here he goes now he's gonna rush the C
pawn probably you can keep the bishop
you can actually get the bishop on
either diagonal the fact that you
highlighted that long-term idea that the
square is the wrong code that Bishop was
really important because it means you
had to go for a more accurate way to
approach and he did you couldn't just
win the piece and then ultimately think
you're gonna win so here he he used
that's super good stuff there this is
this is stuff we learned from use the
King side as a decoy to get the bigger
the bigger thing at stake which is
ultimately to win this King is just
completely out of play and the game is
over here so just really good stuff good
stuff
yeah and do two one the last time he was
down four points of the match he needs
to win again he just needs to keep this
within what are they two games even
three games seems a lot considering I do
think Geary is strong enough in bullet
to maintain that lead but anything can
happen in bullet as has been seen year
after year in the speech Chess
Championship well and again his comeback
against Alexander grishnack for those of
you who weren't here at the start of the
show we started off with a clip where
young Chris stuff overcame a two-game
deficit that they had in Poland and
ultimately beat grishnack and overtime
last year or actually no right before
overtime would commence so um so yeah
it's I don't think it's over by a
longshot but you're right i think the
main the worst thing is you kind of feel
like dude is a little tired
psychologically he's uh he's been
beating himself a couple times which is
which is not something that's ever a
good sign for anybody
but okay well this this these kind of
lines often involve blacks sacrificing a
piece though you can play like d4 here
and say here's my knight enough six I'm
going to take back and I'm gonna have
three pawns for that piece it's a very
complicated position I would need
Borissov rooks book to tell you what the
deal is but this is known sort of a
sacrifice whatever you're someone who
can't read good well then there is the
derek zoolander school france who can't
read good ready and just that you
mentioned Borissov ropes bug no I'm
kidding but you're right and this is
this is a lot of theory giri i guess
taking his time to try to remember what
he likes to do here not a fan of this
decision this is good for white right i
mean you've got the dominant center the
double pawns and knight on the edge how
does white take advantage of all this
capitalize when you can well you start
with Bishop III and what natural moves
I'd say go after the pawn on c5 because
you can always take on e7 you don't do
that right away and I think would be a
rushed decision to take on e7 right
right and John De Niro disc II
Grandmaster Geum narrow disc II you of
course can follow him on Twitter see
streams regularly but showing up in the
chat saying he agrees that Duda is the
more experienced bullet player so
wouldn't be surprised if he saw a
comeback okay Bishop e6 played you said
you didn't want to take earlier robber
because it would have been impatient to
do so but now is the time he trades on
e7 White has the bishop pair and going
from this act going for the attack let's
remind everybody while we have their
attention of the other matches that are
upcoming remember we still have plenty
of action here in the 2019 speeches
championship Aronian faroush ax that's
when I know you circle big time on your
calendar right Ali Reza is the kid from
Iran that many people look at it's just
a future global super superstar but
playing against 27 80 plus players is a
different animal right I'm not gonna lie
I see a Ronan as the favorite they're
disagreeing with a lot of people at
the same reason I picked away ye is the
favorite over Purusha in the jr. speech
s I think the stronger player will win
in a long match but all right mom ad yah
reverses so that'll be on Wednesday
October 2nd also another big one I have
no idea who to take in that matchup and
then we've got the the big dog hey Cara
Nakamura himself as the 1 seed taken on
the 16th seed - bro so you think
Vladimir the big dog I wasn't sure who
you were referring to there Dobrev
Dubrow
he's who's that here who's the big dog
he's he's a big guy but I would consider
a car like a more than big dog remember
he did let the dogs out we answered that
question of who who let them out
it was Hikaru that will be here all week
don't forget to tip your waitress all
right Bishop takes age six a brilliant
move you're trying to pry open the f6
square
Knight f6 check is the problem everybody
that's why Bishop takes h6 happened yep
and now you leave that Bishop on h6 cuz
you still don't want to take it for the
reasons of the f6 square so but Bishop
f4 seems simple enough just treating you
stole upon now Knight g5 threats are
real oh man
because the run g2 will hit that
rook on d5 not good news for Gary's
defense yeah did he just blow under aged
six while we were answering the question
of who let the dogs out right here rook
d5 I think he just missed it yeah
just straight up well the c5 home is
also hanging so he kind of oh that's
true I guess he was already in a tough
spot it was a bit of a fork not the kind
of fork you normally think of but this
is kind of a fork and Judah might be
about to about to strike back here look
at the combination he just executed with
Knight f6 check discovery on the rook on
d5 oh my gosh we didn't have time to
finish the end due to just you know just
smashed him you know whoa okay if he
once again and this comes back to two
games baby I'm sorry I'm not sorry i
coli told yourself bullet is coming it's
too late now to say sorry
the winter is coming for defer if you're
if you're Geary right now you want to
have an edge headed into bullet yeah
you don't want to use momentum to do -
that's for sure and right now dude up
playing really good chess and well just
take any for it some trades going you
know you just don't lose that's it and
how much time is left four and a half
minutes about in this time segment but
he's going for the structure once more
where he's gonna try to play for c5 and
and get the bishop on long
diagonal
hold on g3 I don't wish it was back a
square right you want upon g2 you closed
the diagonal and whoa but not if you
cancel long I was gonna say if you're
all-in you don't care so much in fact
now I want it on g4 here we go wow that
was the surprising decision to me but
he's gone for aggressive intentions in
the kingside if I'm black I'm thinking
about taking on e4 just in general right
if you have less space I don't want to
trade pieces here are the pieces that
remain more space for your remaining
pieces so you'll do it
I put the other night on f6 but but look
for this has now become a very much like
a certain variation of the classical
French white has a few things you can do
here sometimes you can even give up the
bishop error in exchange for the
initiative h4 and chief or get on the
agenda you just try to rush it okay he
decides probably the more practical
decision here if you're not really that
confident your attack keep the two
bishops try to play on both sides of the
board including the center here with the
knight coming to e5 at some point Bishop
e7 now though there's a problem at
diagonal this should be seven I mean
okay like okay he plays c5 first he's
got your idea I think do two agrees with
you but you can play Bishop c3 here as
Geary or take first and then you move
whoa wait we're gonna get an exchange
sac I'm calling it now something nasty
is about to go down in this game this is
this is gonna get wild the Knights
coming to g5 threats on h7 Bishop comes
to c3 this is complicated here Wow
Bishop c3 right now yeah well I like
this now dude this is this is how you
sacrifice it's not good but you win
anyway how I do it it's the Danny run
that's how I do it
go into your bag of tools you'll find a
wrench sacrifice done soundly 95 never
it
I would never sacrifice a wrench that's
a tool you need forever
all right 94 94 yeah
notice that dooda dooda was afraid of
the sack he didn't take h1 because it
was about to get real over here
but that means kiri might have just
gotten away with that pawn because oh
wait because if you take it you're
allowing a discovery fix we have six and
you're gonna meet it your dirty dog
hitting my bishop and a1 all right so I
have to settle on Bishop c3 yeah he does
it agreed a great town it looks good for
white though right because that you've
this very typical three-on-two advantage
from the Queen side which is more
powerful than the four on three on the
Kings side because hard to mobilize
blacks pawns too quickly I ever played
Bishop b4 here to trade off the bishops
because the won't c3 is the best
white piece in the board and does it and
I actually really don't like rook d2
because of this would be I think rookie
two is a mistake
yeah I agree and now black actually okay
it's small but maybe has some small
chances and of course as you look at the
time this may be his chance right to
bring things within striking distance if
you're do to trying to get a victory
here as black could be huge likely this
will be our last three minute game here
unless something horrific happens in the
next 30 seconds which you know and blitz
it always can Danny
this position who do you think is better
chances to win this game I like black a
fine I like to just because it's not
even it's it's the open King in time
pressure b5 yeah alright just as good
right I mean it's the open King and time
pressure that we smell that we smell
here as a problem objectively I think
both sides should be fine but I think
black has the better chances I think I
definitely prefer an a5 to b5 I mean
after 85 you're just going 85 84 it's
very straight forward here this feels
like you're allowing white to liquidate
a bit because if you take on c4 now then
there's a bunch of trades but 85 84 felt
super good breaking open the a file okay
yeah maybe you're right I still think
that black would be Illinois with
chances and maybe you can play a 5 now
still of
you have to watch out for things like
hey he goes for it but there's backdoor
ideas like Queen b7 but I still think
black maybe has your idea in mine oh
yeah Queen b7 definitely an interesting
move I feel like then I'm over b8 and
just kind of continue my attack yeah
you're right though you call this you
know black having the good attacking
chances and white sort of yeah this it's
also a practical thing as we look at
time pressure now commencing a four I
think I mean why not see these things b5
oh that's right I'm forced to trickling
sorry I thought I had a tactic on c2 and
taking with Czech but no I have to deal
with the Queen first so he trades he'll
back up to b6 with a temp on f2 okay or
b7 trying to squeeze like and just offer
traits he was going to go like f3 or g2
yeah he still he still does he still
wants f3 still wants g2 a forza moved to
consider if you can force the Queen away
and then and then come in does it work I
don't know we're gonna find out black is
black is in control because of the
practical factor here everyone this
could be a two game match heading into
bullet yep I mean where's that Queen
blue on Queenie for a check along Queen
Queens that's the one thing that really
doesn't rate Queens you lose your
winning chances and he is now under 30
seconds okay now you have Queenie for a
three does nothing okay don't do it rook
b8 yep that's a good move oh wow oh it's
a double attack on the Queen and the
rook but it's Queenie you protect both
Queen a8 what a nice fine robber but
that's what we're treating move I'm not
sure do two will find in our time
fresher you also have to deal with rook
c7 after that I forgot my ring
successful but yeah I think he might
just be settling now because rook c7
would have been a would have been a
problem what a great move by kiri Queen
up for it's a hard move to play because
now look how ugly the pawn structure is
and black is just a few moves away Mike
King age 17 g 16 age 5 yep here it comes
here comes the King I have no idea who's
better here I think white is you can't
kapeniak v is rook c5 check oh that's
what is it
okay you can't allow look see five that
would have forced a winning team upon
ending where Charlie is a girl on c8
okay so that was a good move about five
yeah twenty-one seven seconds left go do
it
I like this nice move garde g7 to make
sure there's no rook she's six and
you're threatening actually King q4 oh
you should start with rook p7 when you
in Ruby does about me yeah we see a lost
him a critical tempo what a great point
we'll highlight that right before we go
to break and show that instructive
moment for all the viewers here I think
now we're gonna see a draw that might
have been the game actually the fact
that Duda didn't find rook b7 to be
honest yeah I think it was probably
likely going to be a split point either
way but it did feel like that could've
been a very critical temp is gonna peter
out to a draw so let's bring up the
analysis board and all this back up here
and show you the key thing Robert
highlighted was that back in this
position when the rook retreated right
here the rook didn't need to go to b8
could have gone to b7 to hold the pawns
and if we get similar lines as to the
game the fact that you don't have to
worry about things like this at the rook
were already on b7 you'd see black
taking and maybe getting out or even
King g4 right away
alright well perhaps it wouldn't have
been enough anyway
what we do know is that right now we
head into the bullet portion Geary
holding strong there Robert Judah did
not overcome a three game deficit
against Alexander grishnack last year he
overcame a two game deficit so now he's
down he's down a little bit more than he
was in his previous comebacks but he is
the favorite and many people's eyes and
bullets so don't go anywhere when we
return the fastest portion of this match
in the 2019 speeches championship when
we return
[Music]
and as we return and have the attention
of 6000 viewers here let's remind you
that the other major event coming up is
the first time we have ever had the
honor of being involved in an officially
recognized World Chess Championship that
of course is the Fisher random World
Chess Championship it's been going on
for several months now but we are
finally down to the quarterfinals the
weekend October 4 through 6 should be
circled big time on your calendar
because we have 8 of the world's best
human beings these are the only players
left standing of literally thousands of
people who paid an entry to try to play
in this event including a lot of title
players and of course the top three of
those 8 will move on to Oslo to join the
world champion Magnus Carlsen for the
title so Robert and I will have the live
call of that event right here from
Studio C we're flying Robert into the
studio he loves sitting next to me don't
you Robert don't you Robert yes you like
sitting next to me yes something like
that but chess Bay has it great I'm not
saying all of them wearing the same
shirt at the same time hey there we go
yeah Studio C we have another chair and
if you thank you Oren thank you thank
you see Robert that's right you're
joining soon I won't physically reach
over unless I need you welcome back
everyone the 2019 speed chess
championship continues here we have the
bullet portion straight up ahead many
people look at Yong Christophe dude as
the favor here we'll see if he can prove
those predictions true because he's
gonna need to down three games against
the Dutchman we have liftoff the bullet
is on I'm pumped for this Danny I'm pop
I know you're also pumped me it comes to
next to you so we can commentate
together that way we can finish each
other's sandwiches in real life that's
right right
all you want that's right we both like
we both like Jimmy John's from time to
time you know when you're starving any
sandwiches good all right we've got a
bruh goes in for the first time so I
always wonder in the bullet if there's
something these players have saved and
they're planning on busting out likely
that's not the case and it's sort of
sometimes happens instinctive
naturally but but sometimes it is when
we talk to the players of course if this
is your first SCC remember we will
interview them win or lose both players
join us after every match and give us a
breakdown so I think they'd like this
position for bullet because there are
very clear plans for both sides who's a
backwards c6 bond for black which needs
defending but you're a little bit more
active on the Kings side you have the
two bishops namely the bish one d6 is a
strong piece because white doesn't have
a Darkspore bishop and look at look at
both these guys these guys are playing
like nervous Nellie's in the bullet
neither side wanted to think that was a
bad decision by deer in your Bishop e6
they sort of blunder yeah II four is
very powerful
here comes e5 that lady is running out
of squares can you say g3 because it's
coming on the bishops pins oh it's that
this is the first of what I believe will
be a few victories for Duda and bullet I
don't know that I'm calling the epic
comeback but I'm calling I'm calling
this is gonna be the toughest portion
for a niche and he may end up meeting
that lead before this day is over well
so the bishop is kind of trapped too
like Brooke it what a move nice move
putting it on a protected square so that
he can just go ahead and put Queenie one
technique the technique do - does the
I've landed all along I planned it all
along look obviously Giri said young
Christopher Duda has excellent tactical
alertness and vision and due to himself
said he looks forward to the bullet
feels like he's the favorite there so I
don't know this match has gone a little
too close to storyline if your Giri for
to feel comfortable right now he's down
a piece and I think he's about to to
lose this game he's definitely resigning
I think it's a bad decision but I think
that was a bad decision
- he's forgetting the match strategy but
I'm trying to shake myself off here cuz
I'm burning I'm burning it up this is
gonna this is gonna be hot fire at the
end of the show today I can feel it I
mean I'm into it right now because this
decision by Giri to play into this
structure once more they aligned black
to Castle quickly Bishop d7 play for c5
but feels just it feels accommodating in
the words of the man who do - looks like
I'm never gonna let you down I'm never
gonna give you up I'm gonna make that
bullet comeback happen pretty sure
that's what the song said right before
you Rick Rolled I don't didn't think I
can like that song any less and you
really just hey I'm never gonna lose
this match never gonna play too fast
never gonna never there we go the the
match continues okay White's position is
amazing here yeah Gary's about to bounce
back here these are two very happy pawns
two on one on the queenside that's uh
that makes due to an unhappy boy a six
was a bit strange I guess you you
removed the opportunity for keeping the
tension there and now and now Duda puts
a knight on it actually he must like it
when Knights coming to c6 he's gonna
Park it there speaking of liking things
putting Knights on him I like c6 a
sevens a weakness yeah this looks like
Gary's returning the favor and look at
the time again people talked about due
to being the faster better ball player
giri he came with a message today look
at this he just took a walk stop
criticizing his opening because it
worked out perfectly ping hae also your
dude you might want to resign to save
time yeah doesn't know you need to come
back and okay you can play like Queen f5
and just continue to sit tight g4 I
guess that says you open the position
why can't move yes moves the Knights at
D 7 he's just gonna play tickle between
D so no he's not he's going to the Kings
side but feels very risky he's going
from him anyway that's what boys all
about a7 being sacrificed for counter
play he's laughing at the pawn saying I
want the King yep here he's gonna call
his bluff not h5 if you take you a
Brooke g5 check and you win the Queen oh
my gosh Gary and see that this is why
Judah is so tactically resourceful as
gary said in the
we showed a moment ago dude just 1985
though when he takes what oh you can't
stop the pond wow what a nice way to
finish the game though yep and due to
some of us still has chances a few does
even after that very sick competition
there Queen 65 who would you actually
take in a practical game the Queen of
the Night vs the open king I might but
does the past be pond the night before
the Queen's coming in I'm feeling
nervous for Gary yep the bullet portion
this is where it gets tricky look at do
tonight h4 is coming to h5 as well you
can't please this dude Duda is just Duda
not gonna do da zippity-doo-dah game
here yeah
Oh watch out for 92 check ideas Matti to
check doesn't quite work right away in
fact suddenly he let whoa
we took a period 23 seconds left the end
of the game super impressive clock
management
I think Gary's got the assert the
assertion in his brain he can't let
himself be the one playing slower on the
bullet cuz he already knows he's up
against it
against the Polish fighter who is the
higher rate of bullet player on our
server you can just see it right there
so Gary clearly coming with the extra
effort being made here yeah and look at
this Kings Indian wire is already trying
to break through on the Queen side and
black is gonna play for f5 but it's not
gonna do too much I always like these
positions for white especially in a
bullet time control I know hit card
Nakamura with rolls eyes at me easy
player through and through but if you
just look at the position right now
White has the better pawn structure and
the Knights are stable he picks in d6
but nice little shot there well I just
you know I figured that and I know I'm
gonna have to eat my words at some point
but I might as well own up to it right
away right before I that's my strategy
to insult myself before her caro-kann
yep there you go good life's tragic all
right 91 played white is better I agree
with you but the practical reason say
carro plays this line a lot is because
black ultimately gets play on the
kingside against the king okay play c6
they're not bad if you can think about
we'd see five wins abuse queen c5 bonus
it would have won a piece these guys
haven't haven't been real into winning
pieces today no definitely not okay
buddy five squares calling my name
he just won her piece anyway mr. James
d6 he's just on just blocked his own
Queens protection what is due to
thinking about dude he's making sure no
he's not he's gonna get me dude how many
free pieces has he missed in this match
how oh my gosh can we get a clip
compliation of how many times due to
miss the win of a night Queen takes c6
and the first time controlled Bishop
takes d6 here I'm still in disbelief oh
my god oh my gosh and the game is still
super complicated right now with tactics
in the d5 square wait wait okay there's
got to be a good move here Knight takes
e4 looks like Bishop e7 is coming Oh
watch out Bishop e7 he finds that okay
Duda may win this game anyway so it may
not be the the catastrophe that the
previous one was where if you missed the
five minute portion everyone shame on
you we had an exciting back and forth
affair but and one of the critical
moments of the match due to miss the
free win of a piece that Geary saw we
saw his reaction on camera but then Duda
didn't find it so kind of a very similar
moment there guess who's up on time this
game though oh dude it is his position
it's so good that bish won't have six
yep
it's one of those positions where you
want your Bishop a knight to share the
fcc's five yeah that's the only problem
with White's position is that it's too
good both people piece yeah oh no Jay
Kingi
that's a nice maybe seven Queen takes
would have been made on 88 or on that
was Robert's tactic but but he just
takes instead that's sick if you take
with neither piece it's made on h8
I love it although it does even win by
force because you took bishop a bishop
f8 is over did you feed okay Wow Duda is
gonna get this game I'm gonna call it I
think I think so the miss piece is not
gonna be the same storyline as earlier
but Wow oh my gosh what a nice way to
finish there and forcing the easy
conversion I love that move
considering the number of blunders I was
just worried he actually Mouse for a
second - when I first saw it I didn't
immediately see Bishop e5 but then I
realized it was good okay unless there's
a weird stalemate about to happen here
I would I would advise you not to
stalemate your opponent no if I were
allowed to give advice
okay Duda who do two takes that advice
we have a two-game match nineteen and a
half minutes remain still plenty of
opportunities for both players to show
who's gonna dominate the bullet portion
and plenty of opportunities for us to be
hype shoutout to all nearly 6,500 of you
that are with us thanks for being here
by far the most exciting match I think
we've had so far in the 2019 speech has
championship that's not the daily
question but let us know your thoughts
whether you also agree this was the best
match use the hash tag speech yes and by
the way I want to give a huge shout-out
to our mods doing so much work and the
community here today Robert has been
clipping everything thank you so much
we've had so many clips everyone
actively engaged the chess TV chat also
been super positive so thank you to
everyone who's here no matter where you
choose to watch our show yeah thank you
very much and right now down Chris up
dude
we then I trapped on e5 yeah that's the
move you want back we're about to have a
second win in a row for Duda we are
about to have
oMG Zoar snaps he resigns we have a one
game match everyone game on resigning in
an position with the same amount of
material is generally not a good sign
maybe something went really really wrong
and right there he just got a shot we
have a Berlin in a bullet game you know
they say never go Berlin in the bullet
and I've definitely never heard that
before but you know you you make up a
lot of phrases with you okay
I I agree though it's very usually bad
advice now Gary only up the game you
don't want to go over linen the bullet
it's usually an easier position for
white oh my gosh this is a great
position for white we play these things
do it dat one can do that oh my god
forcing the bishop away for c7 to fall I
just bend my foot on the ground and it
hurt because I'm not wearing shoes
because I go flipping in my flops when
there's a party down low and business up
top flipping in my flops man your lyrics
are bottomless I know we're the hip-hop
bottom that's right oh my god fight is
definitely in control this is a harder
position for black to play for sure this
could be a tide match makes you nervous
if you're a Giri fan 97 bring it to f5
keep poking keeper to just guard e5
first you can also play see four in some
of those positions and just use d5
permanently but he goes for the patient
approach white owns the D file here
that's why this is a two result position
for the first player okay okay Gary I
see you I see you baby
here he goes so is he gonna go rook t4
and just say I would say C for hopefully
eight for next or he's gonna keep you
can be too right because you see I was
gonna say you still on the d5 with one
rook ah but Giri he stops he stops the
slow plane of guarding me to rook t5
good move there move this might be how
you over press the okay wait wait the
king of all he goes for it is it a lost
King upon ending I don't know I think
white is better why it's better because
you're gonna get the past h1 you can
lose a tempo right you can oh we know it
doesn't matter you end up sacrificing h4
f and the king will be closer to the
king to the Queen side
over there so the white king wants to do
more work but you might be right it's
really okay think you're counting right
he was considering King e6 there but he
goes for G for the whole point everyone
is whichever pawn is farthest away from
the the other action that's what he
tried to he tried to trick him into
playing g5 because then he would have
had the h-bomb but still white didn't
fall for it White's winning we are gonna
have a tight match Geary allows the
trade into a lost King upon ending
buckle up everyone don't drink too much
coffee before a chest show cuz what
happens is my heart rate is beating at
about 160 beats a minute right now and
it's not healthy I am but I'm not gonna
stop drinking coffee this is a pretty
well played game though I mean we've
seen a lot blenders a lot of missed free
pieces and look at this hiccup on a team
before I'm thinking before it's over
Gary loses this is this is a match we
have a tied affair here with 15 minutes
remaining you thought we were hyping we
were being real Duda is favorite and
bullet in a lot of people's eyes giri
has got to stop the bleeding now and
show that he's not gonna get steamrolled
here in the fastest segment Robert what
do you do your Gary's coach like what
has he got to do here to go with the
obvious play better no but on a serious
note he's he knows himself that he's not
the best polo player in the world and he
just needs to just like somehow find his
groove yeah what he's doing right now is
he's playing super fast which has been
working for him in some games but him
plenty of games exactly backfire so he's
over min on the clock he's doing well
considering it's the opening stage of
the game but he's allowing Duda in
critical moments to break through and
like break free and that's big problem
for him he needs just and sure I like
the waist in Chile in this position it's
very slow-paced game which I think suits
his style better than does do this
because dude it will make moves like d5
no c5 just keep playing the long game
here
look at that Bishop on b7 it's a pawn oh
just keep playing three items just just
keep playing slowly alright taking I
wouldn't have done but he's gonna I
don't want to go have four
what do you think Danny F for often
becomes a move you want back I agree
with this approach this is this is
probably better cuz c5 well anyway oh
yeah there's no a d4 for black and
usually you just give up the pawn play
against these meat pawns okay the
problem is now you're parting with the
bishop here and I think I think Gary's
better here I think this is an
opportunity for him to slow things down
there's a threat of Bishop before the
knight is pinned on c5 to the queen he
goes for it now you can put the Queen on
d2 to gang up and then try for f4 f5
I like that somewhat blacks last time
play d4 and just offering exchange of
bishops than play Knight g5 7 points:5 I
still think URI this is one of those
like like scotch games for white where
the four-on-three majority is is very
dangerous in the middle game White's
gonna get an attack here with f5 what
did black plays at five right now well
then I don't know what to do Robert
you can you wait Tommy you wouldn't play
a 5 so I had to do it first hey well you
know what that's why we're here we
complete each other's a5 which is Oh F
okay Jesus were 6 oh he's giving up f4
with tempo wait what that takes up for
only a free bond good talk this looks
good from black I mean yeah I agree
though he didn't take it for but the
Giri is is in big trouble now that the
attack has been stopped
young Christoph flexing in the bullet
portion right now we were students left
Oh God this is not going well rook takes
t4 you're laughing at Queen Chi for
what's wrong with you how do you defend
this what's this there's no mate how do
you made if you're Duda the Queen go
back to d5 and you're holding all the
critical squares there's no unreal yeah
actually Gary's somehow holding it there
was never a checkmate oh here comes the
night though oh that's another piece
that you're not happy to see Queen h3
Queen age 3 hits the rook in each - and
it's over
Oh Oh SpaghettiOs checkmate with the
rook yeah shakes his head he didn't even
see the mate coming on h2 that is not a
good Stein not Stein
Leonard Stein also a great player Wow
Leonard all right now I mean we want to
see kiri
find himself here the match is hot fire
we have an epic comeback underway Anish
geary no longer in the lead he was up
for games at one point in this match
it could have maybe even been war but
there's also been some really crazy
moments of opportunities missed so this
is this has been entertaining and I
think we'd like to in each this position
the last time we got into this dynamic
but he allowed efore in that critical
moment so he as long as he prevents wife
from breaking with E for and you can
just play on the kingside he's still way
up on the clock like he has not been
losing a bullet because of time he's
really made a concerted effort yeah this
is free reign on the kingside he's
present that in a five well not yet
actually that was a really irritating
sequence because now he has to deal with
the beat one yeah this is this is
getting all the sudden dude is in
control again that is backfired dude it
just looks so confident right now you
should be like I said it's like I
planned this all along right into my
trap 93 95 now okay Queen b7 also looks
pretty good but 93 he's coming and
you're not gonna be happy about it
yep the c6 pawn is a problem Oh 95
okay rook c5 super precise you stop c5
first
now the knight is being threatened to
either a 5 or a 4 but the Queen might
get traveling on 97 your Queen's in
pretty big danger ooh did he go holy
Rosa Purusha a trap his own queen is the
boat says gambit he went full ollie
Reza's trapped his Queen on b7 never go
full Ollie Reza never do it how does
this Queen get out actually spend a lot
of time years on 20 seconds actually he
just lost his Queen that's why you means
in we see though now you can really get
a good picture of
rickroll the rookie and then rook either
were to be ate the problems rook takes
p5 is threatened okay I think you
survived he gets out you I know I'm a
sly dog sometimes silly Robert Trix are
for kids
Wow whoopsies b5 opens mate no doesn't
work it's does fathers night c8 oh he
found it yes he they both saw it so he
backs up and tucks his tail between his
legs Geary happily wins the pawn back
and he may be better now put a rook on
c4 okay you got him in decanted ball
very nice he stopped 95 maybe g5 at some
point for white just give the you 95
square okay
blacks in no not so fast I like this I
like this for Geary he's up a little bit
on the clock right got a back up the
rook No
get aggressive in trade but still you're
gonna have to fight for the a file
that's what he does King he's gonna play
King d6 to over guard the pawn then he
can free the knight to some other kind
of maneuver f5 working feint kind of
stuff okay but then c6 is hanging be
careful yep okay you're right you're
right look f3
very nice hidden force work h1 and here
comes the other night here we go night
before
Knight comes to aim for Geary is out
playing him here in this engine look at
the time scramble yep just play 94 tape
with a pawn in a you have stick position
right now for black and if he takes King
tanks and the King goes the b4 as a pro
King takes here comes the King uppity
for zapato you Brooke e5 rookie fellow
he had rookie 5 he had rookie 5 playtime
but but now his king is one temple
behind yep had it he had it he has to
play on rook
oh he's gonna take the draw oh my god
that was his opportunity to win his
black and level the match due to barely
gets by we have 7 and a half minutes
Geary and must win territory now I am
crazy you know that that game was so
close and Geary deserves all the props
position was bad yep but he fought
really hard he lost a pawn early on but
because he played so quickly in the
opening he had like a 20-second lead at
some point
able to fight his way back in right now
with the white pieces he keeps doing
what he's been doing
look at the clock here anis trying to do
his best to car Nakamura impersonation
playing faster than he needs to has more
time than he started with and he's white
needs to make more faces if he's gonna
go for the car Nakamura sure I'll give
him that advice after the show Oh Mischa
takes f6 now that's a problem and it
actually happens even on h6 because you
have a four key mode yep
and that's what he always doing it right
now Bishop takes f6 fork town population
you the 1916 to h7 he's got it
you didn't sit with the pawn there why
six for sure oh we know there's nothing
there's Queen f3
but give it t take any six right take on
these six White's winning a pawn
yeah I'm upon opposite colored bishops
whoa Oh sir he wants the same color
Bishop position but I don't know why why
did you do that easy go for the endgame
with the three on two on the Queen side
but this will be more okay ghost King f1
instead but I was gonna say you got a
free the rank before the rook can get
frisky
that was interesting he Aguirre knows he
needs to win there's only five okay six
minutes I guess on the game clock giri
in must win territory I'm not really
like to use winning chances in this game
either it slipped you might lose this
game actually uh okay look at the time
by the way these two guys are playing
fast very good matched I agree and I
definitely prefer blacks position now
because I don't know
okay not a Pidgey for it g4 as they move
the clothes of the board down and says
you're not you know nothing's happening
that's happening here maybe that's match
strategy maybe that's match strategy do
too knows the situation oh wait but now
you could lose the endgame if you're
black if everything gets traded white
might lose his endgame that's what I'm
thinking I'm really liking black this is
just so much more ax I didn't realize
how fast the move the move e5 comes in
this is actually a passed pawn and fury
knows how to use it I'm a bit surprised
he took with the opponent the King on e5
yeah perhaps
because then you had f5 and a for coming
I agree and the G pawn would have been
really good okay you're right okay why
does Bishop a5 now also Gary really
needs to hold this game because using
this one mathematically puts him in puts
him in due to territory right you got to
win the final two games as due to did
versus Grichuk last year yep so Gary
Gary cannot lose this game whether he
wins it or not he cannot lose this game
time watch out for Duda he's spending a
lot of time there play Bishop d3 yeah
baby you just sit tight and settle and
take your chances in the next one I
don't know he wants to be four okay e4
super committal though that's a super
committal move that rook can't move from
d4 that's good news
yep at some point black might play a
four and just like a bishop beat one oh
they're gonna settle Wow that was four
minutes left we are officially in I
don't know we're in almost the last game
territory right now we've got a crazy
match here a one game lead for young
Christopher Duda it all comes down to
these final few minutes you know I think
two games probably left and I see then
there did the gym notice he done he was
saying a four at some point yeah I think
that you two had all the winning chances
yeah but keeping his lead he's
maintaining his lead and he's probably
happy with that
yep and how an issue on the black side
of this position is hanging pawns which
is very good when you need to win games
because you don't want symmetry you
don't want you to equality here you just
want to play for a different structure
where both sides have different plans
and you can try to outplay your opponent
especially when you're moving so quickly
and you're more time than sorry well as
he redoes huge shout out to the
community with us thanks for being here
subs to show our support we appreciate
all 7000 of you this has been quite the
match the 2019 speeches championship
just rolls on here the most exciting
event in online chess may be the most
exciting event in chess am I allowed to
say that yet Robert it's a it's a very
great I love doing the commentary all
right white white just needs a draw
almost that's the issue if you're here
Giri has got to get the kind of activity
you need an isolated Queen palm position
you have more active minor pieces here
as black but all all all due to needs to
do is get a ton of time off the clock
and not lose he's up again it's getting
close that time looking at how much time
is left in the match how much time they
have in this game but I'd like what
Gerry is doing once again he's getting
active on the Kings side at some point
he's either gonna sack on g3 and try to
meet him or he's just gonna play g5 and
break through so Knight takes t3 first
you got a trade and then I put the other
night on e4 for sure Bishop c8 comes to
mind yep there it is coming dangerous
this is the kind of game Gary needs this
is John both winners both players have
gone full thinking man had in hand
statue Oh
human mission g4 there and it has to
keep the rook on the second-ranked f2s
falling acting sagging on g3 next move
96 g3 after rookie see - oh my god these
comas do with the clutch we cage six
Queens good you got the a three-point
hanging f3 Knight is hanging I didn't
like Queen at five it felt like it put
the Queen in a vulnerable square and
here comes right oh oh you could be
right Queen h6 might have been better
okay I'm kind of night chief Knight g5
happening soon there's gotta be like
rook takes she - there's Bishop h3 all
right you want a g5 Queen c7 this could
be the match if he misses this you need
to take that night why could okay seven
his g7 uh-oh this could be it
young christophe Duda he could be moving
on a less Gary swindle something nasty
got nothing here
he's got nothing and he resides he's not
aware of the match situation he's
running out of time Judah's moving on
Duda is unbelievable my gosh
he is the comeback kid this is no ifs
ands or buts about it
he is the comeback kid
and he has just held on he is gonna be
moving on to the next round a
heartbreaking way for this match to
finish against young Kristoff Duda for a
nice Giri it's over 20 seconds not
enough time to overcome a two-game
deficit I thought he was gonna win that
game as black Robert he had the attack
it felt like Gary's game I'm sure there
was something there you know I just felt
like there had to be after that sack a
queen up five putting on a vulnerable
square I think that's what kind of did
him in there and he just let the white
pieces fly free and Duda was able to
pick up the victory this game will count
toward the total score remember in the
speeches championship format every game
has a little bit of something on the
line cash is split based on win
percentage is obviously the winner get
some guarantee cash and then the rest of
it is divvied up based on the total and
final score so this this does count
toward the match in terms of our format
here although unfortunately we can
officially say young Christopher Duda is
moving on unfortunately I guess if
you're a nice Geary's in a nice Geary's
camp wow what an exciting match couldn't
have asked for more
the players have been officially
informed I think I think they're aware
the time is out super disappointing end
to a day that has been one that was
better for Geary overall in the blitz
there but you knew as due to kept it
close Robert he kept it within striking
distance that it was part of his plan
similar to a car Nakamura talking about
his match versus Wesley so right last
year where he member if you remember hey
Cara was down two games against Wesley
so as well right in the blitz portion
but ultimately came back and bullets so
that's kind of how we like the format
right it you know the competitive
balance with bullet only being a half an
hour it kind of makes it about equal to
the Blitz portions in terms of the
overall effect on the match score and
that leads to a lot of these really
close affairs even if one side is better
in the in the 1-1 segment yeah in
hindsight the way this match started
with due to out playing Geary in the
first game and letting him escape with
his draw it did feel like Duda was
actually playing quite excellent chess
despite being down I won't point up to
four games yep and that was a big
problem for dude he just couldn't
convert good
getting in time trouble in the slower
time patrols but once it got to bullet
he was a speed demon
he earned this victory you know he got a
feel for a nice giri who against anybody
else probably would have had this match
wrapped up but against a determined Duda
wasn't meant to be
yeah well Anna Nisha is a little bit
better here maybe goes on to win this
final obstacle Bishop endgame would be a
nice consolation prize that's like
another 50 bucks in his pocket I think
cash money but okay he will not be
moving on to the second round sad for
the Dutchman even though it was a very
very close and exciting match I can't
wait to get these guys thoughts on on
how it went down so don't go anywhere
right after this game we will have a
very very quick break and then we will
be joined by the players for post match
interviews and and then we'll wish you
the best weekend you can right Robert
it's Friday Friday gotta play some
speech chess on Friday please don't do
that
you know I reckon black is painful for
every in bullet bullet yeah play a
bullet it's Friday Friday Friday what
your kids are too young to know that but
I hope they start seeing that to annoy
you they won't RB Rebecca that's the rap
part what it what does it do to do he
just he does it do to does it do to gone
and done it do to gone and done it again
the comeback kid continuing to show why
he is one of the best in the world and
unfortunately for him he falls in the
last game but fortunately he moves on
the players will be officially informed
now as this game will be aborted that
the match is over time has run out yon
kristef Duda wins
Anish now knows it when we return we
will have interviews with our players
the final score 14 and a half to 13 and
a half in favor of young Christophe Duda
we'll be right back
[Music]
that night while I could row k7 history
700 this could be it
young Christophe Duda he could be moving
on a less giri swindle something nasty
got nothing here
he's got nothing and he resides he's not
aware of the match situation he's
running out of time Judah's moving on
Duda is unbelievable my gosh
and we are now joined by our players who
gave us what we can say unequivocally
was by far the most exciting speech
chess match we've had so far
in this year's event Anish we'll start
with you I know obviously it didn't end
the way the way you wanted it to you
hoped it would it felt like it felt like
it was your match they're heading into
the bullet and what are your thoughts
now reflecting about where it got away
from you yeah well in the critical
moments they're right right down the
stretch it felt like a couple of the
games were super close to converting is
it just that the faster format they're
harder to harder to put away a couple
games that seemed better for you I think
it goes to show you do remember one game
the game where you played knight c6 and
[Music]
so but it seems that you can give me a
couple of pieces on Christopher were you
aware afterwards at any point you never
showed any sort of facial expressions on
camera we could tell the Denise knew he
had blundered the night by how he
reacted did you know that you missed an
opportunity to win a couple free pieces
there was the Italian game where a niche
played Knight to c6 and there was an
opportunity for Queen takes c6 and 97
Fork and had the crowd going crazy so
you know I was missing times like all
the I was missing things like all the
time and actually very lucky as I
managed to okay to play with reasonably
well in bullet because especially three
plus one segment I was playing was close
to beginner acting I mean it was a huge
I thought to me I think to to change my
my mentality because yeah I thought I
was going to lose the match and yeah it
was very tough of you three I was hoping
for
yeah for the bands that I would have
played to go dance it was the case but I
was actually very lucky I think because
I also played reasonably well and it was
just like I think young Chris I have a
question for you about an opening choice
because you played this Vienna variation
a couple times and in that was played by
Magnus Carlsen against Fabiano Carwin
the sea filled cup I personally didn't
like the opening choice for blitz and
what do you know warrior thoughts are
chewing that multiple times okay I was
interested the Polish was playing
against the I didn't check this very
much actually I a preparation was okay I
am prepared I have prepared I and and I
also had many interesting ideas just for
this especially for this match and yeah
okay things and okay later on I switch
to something an issue I know the board
didn't go your way and as you said you
you know the simple analysis is
obviously you played worse than the
bullet but it didn't at the start of the
segment you were way up on the clock it
felt like you were making a concerted
effort that you would be the faster
player in that segment was that was that
part of your preparation or your thought
about coming into the match
that you were really gonna try to play
fast in the final portion no I mean I
was trying to play fast the whole match
I think what went wrong because the
match was sort of mine for the taking
and I realized looking back and probably
a young Christophe tricked me by playing
very bad in the first two segments and
then his level of playing the bullet
like increased dramatically because
looking back and indeed the first part
of the match I think he was giving me so
many chances and I think in some in some
way he spoiled me a little bit if I lost
I lost the you know I was a sense of
danger to some extent because in bullet
you know I had to I was punished much
more rough for my mistakes
yo Christophe you said in your pre match
interview that you felt like the bullet
was your your best portion was that part
of the strategy all along there were a
couple games and blitz that it seemed
like you you've made the game go on
longer than you needed to
there was the opposite code Bishop draw
where it felt like you were kind of
milking the clock to get time was that
part of your strategy to waste time in
the blitz a little bit to get faster
[Music]
sounds Leslie because was like three or
four points behind but yeah I don't know
it was young Chris I have a question for
you when you went down I think three
games in the match you took off your
headphones so were you listening to
music before that and then decided that
it wasn't helping you concentrate yes
[Music]
I didn't I didn't notice that Peniche
you've Aneesh you played some great
speed chess matches you've had a couple
times you've lost but I think both times
you've lost you were wearing that chest
bra hoodie do you want to change the
game now and take the chest for a hoodie
off for future matches yeah I think I
actually like the yeah
makes me look very very scary and I'm
wearing those at home sometimes it goes
no particular thought but yeah maybe if
I keep losing and just run with it and
I'll undress yes well jokes aside
obviously we know it didn't go your way
today there you had a ton of fans in the
chat people people love you here on
Twitch and chests calm and it was a very
very close match if we if there were ten
more minutes on the clock
who knows what would have happened but
young Chris stuff congratulations again
you move on into the second round and
you'll be facing the winner between
Nakamura and Dobrev your thoughts on it
your thoughts on potentially facing her
car Nakamura in the second round young
Kristoff like close to zero I mean like
15 0 or something
especially one plus zero okay Louis
America in Chicago and well I'm getting
you so that's of course is is much
better than me so you're not gonna
guarantee match victory yet you're not
gonna guarantee that you're gonna win
okay
all right guys well we don't have any
more questions thank you so much for
being being with us and putting on quite
a show for the fans today this was
awesome a lot of fun wish you both best
of luck at the World Cup where you're
headed so Anisha I told you no matter
what happens in this match I
love you remember when I said that yeah
it's still the case it's still the case
all right well thank you both again
young Krista best of luck in the second
round I will will let you both get some
rest there we know it's late in Europe
and next time but we'll see you next
time
all right Robert well as our players
depart and we thank them you and I bring
up the bracket here and show the fans
one more time the final score Yann
Christophe Duda barely gets by a nice
giri fourteen and a half three and a
half yeah that was a really close match
and you know I'm actually really excited
about something Danny last year when
young Christophe Duda went on his
magical run he was stopped by Wesley so
and Wesley is an absolute monster as you
see on the other side of the bracket but
I'm really excited to finally see young
Christoph play hey Karl and yes Hikaru
is the heavy favorite young Chris left
himself acknowledged that quite as he's
gotten more experience playing some of
these top players playing Hikaru I think
that's just a matter of time before Yann
Christophe puts it all together and can
really take out such a heavy weight like
acara well he played well and bullet
here against the nigiri he would
certainly have to play well in Bullitt
against a guy like a Cara Nakamura but
it'll be an exciting rest of the year of
course for the speech Chess Championship
for sure that match won't probably go
down till sometime in October so
everyone can be anticipating that we
reminded you earlier in the show of our
of our next few speech chess matches but
there we go that's that's that's pretty
much it I mean we're we're I'm trying
remember the next one up was Aronian
firoozeh that's right so if you look at
the top of the bracket there that's our
next one on the table our team even guru
shocked that's one that I think has a
lot of people curious if we're gonna see
an upset there it's hardly an upset I
guess if Artemyev is considered the
sixth seed but I think a lot of people
look at Grichuk as the more experienced
the favorite but that one that Russian
on Russian action is gonna turn a lot of
keep a lot of people up late at night
watching that show yeah it's very
interesting that side of the bracket I
mean okay of course we just had do two
vs. Geary which was extremely close
can't get closer than a one game match
but the other side the bracket with
those matchups artemyev chris scherk mom
and jar of Wesley so and you know even
Aronian firoozeh these are like pretty
toss-up matches where you know if I were
a betting man I don't know what I would
do because it's very difficult to
separate these players they're all good
at different aspects of the game and
different time controls and we don't
really know it with respect to our team
yet that's the player that I have a big
question mark next to because we seen
his meteoric rise in classical chess and
he is a very talented speed chess player
plays a lot on chess calm plays a lot of
the title Tuesday's he plays blitz a lot
so he does but he just doesn't have the
same you know experience as Grisha just
because he's much younger so I am
curious to see if our team can do a Duda
and defeat some of these very
established players if you're gonna do
it do to make sure it's on the chess
board and that you win those games
Robert thank you so much for being here
I always always a pleasure flying
alongside you here man this this was
exciting I agree with you that I think
the landslide victories are behind us in
the 2019 speech Chess Championship I
think we have a lot of I don't know
what's a total coin tosses but a lot of
close matches up ahead so with that I'm
gonna say goodbye to you my friend and
and say goodbye to the chat here as we
wrap up the show see you and with that
as we said everybody this next match
here of the speeches championship comes
to an end thank you for being with us on
behalf of everybody here at chess calm
thank you for your support your
subscriptions your premium memberships
your viewership being here helps make
all this possible we love you so much
all of our mods my producer mr. are in
Hawaii behind the glass and everybody
else who makes this possible we will see
you next time for the speed chess
championship as we continue here